could everyone please start finding
their seats we'll be starting here
shortly
e
e e
we'll wait one more minute before we
start e
okay good morning everybody let's get
started I was uh delaying the start of
the meeting a few minutes to allow
members to
arrive welcome to the kickoff session of
the science technology and energy
committee for the 2025
2026 legislative session we have a
jam-packed lineup for today before we
get to that though I'm going to ask you
all to stand and join United States Air
Force retired captain and representative
Doug Thomas as he leads us in the Pledge
of
Allegiance I to the of the United States
of America and to the Republic for
stands one nation under indivisible
withy and justice for
all so welcome once again to returning
members and new members the first hour
of our meeting this morning is going to
be committee
orientation we will spend an hour
discussing just exactly how the
committee
operates we will introduce ourselves to
each other both returning and new
members and we'll discuss Basic Ground
rules for conduct here in the
legislative office building and in
committee meetings as well we'll also
talk about the work we do in this
committee there are two major things we
do we hear bills in public hearing
and we pass judgment on those bills in
executive sessions and we will discuss
at length myself my vice chair and my
clerk we will discuss at length how we
conduct ourselves during those two
activities so the first thing to think
about is and this is a question I never
thought about until I got here this
morning and saw people struggling with
it what do you do with your coat when
you get here so there are coat racks in
the hallway near the elevator down here
near the stairway at the end of the
hallway and there is some limited space
for coats in the committee office which
is the uh room that's right across the
hall from our committee
administrator so there is limited space
there for Co you could also put coats
back here in the corner there is a table
back here and a chair that's not being
used that's another space for coats I
never thought about that before but it's
important to know where to put your coat
or your lunch or your briefcase or
whatever so let's get that out of the
mail out of the
way another issue I'd like to discuss
immediately is start time for these
committee
sessions generally speaking we will
attempt to start these meetings at 900
a.m. there will be exceptions sometimes
we'll start at 10: but in general we'll
try to start these meetings at
9:00 I would appreciate it if all of you
could make every effort to get here
before 9:00 so that we have a full house
when we launch our activity at
9:00 I understand that happens and you
can't always make it on time but please
make every effort that you can to get
here on
time it's also important to not for you
to know that if you know you can't
attend a meeting it's important that you
let your caucus leader know that you
can't attend the meeting so that that
person can let me know what your status
is so for Republicans the caucus leader
is vice chair Doug Thomas and for our
Democrats the caucus leader is ranking
member cat
McGee I will be introducing ourselves to
each other in just a moment but I
thought it was important for you to know
that absences are certainly unavoidable
and acceptable but it is good practice
and courteous to the rest of us to let
us know when you can't be in attendance
as you all know we just recently had a
debate about it on the house floor we do
have in this building and in the State
House a Unwritten rule that
you dress appropriately when you attend
meetings in this
building there is no solid definition of
what appropriate is I realize that but
please be sensitive to
the idea that we represent the public
and the public expects us to
look like we
value our
role so business casual attire is
recommended and we'd appreciate it if
you could uh keep that in mind as you
dress in the
morning there's other ground rules that
we want to I want to go over with
you and I think I'll keep doing that
until more people show up because we're
going to have uh introductions here
eventually but I'd like everybody to
show up if possible first um people are
still filing
in so a reminder this is a reminder not
only for members of the committee but
for everyone who who attending these
meetings food and um beverages are not
allowed in these meetings except for
water water drinking water is uh allowed
but other food and beverages are
not and
if any member uh intends to bring his
lunch from home and eat here um
it's okay to bring your lunch bag into
the room and set it in the back
somewhere um but it's discouraged for
you to eat in this room even during
lunch
breaks and that's just to keep the room
clean if any member has a medical issue
while we're in
session we will contact
UM the house committee Services folks
immediately will probably suspend the
meeting if anybody has a serious medical
issue we will get you attended to there
are numerous people in this building who
have uh medical training EMT training
and they can assist us if any member is
in
distress so let us know right away if
you're not feeling well and we will try
to help you address that problem
use of electronic devices we discourage
the use of electronic devices while
we're in public
hearings representative Thomas Doug
Thomas will go over that in a little
more detail when he talks about public
um hearing behavior and
decorum but in general we'd ask that you
uh refrain from using electronic devices
while in the committee room if you need
to consult email or take a phone call
you can always exit the room and do that
in the
hallway representative McGee you have a
question yeah on the uh on the devices
in the room we had this conversation
last orientation as well I know and uh
our uh half of the committee actually
does extemporaneous note taking within
the meetings and within the hearings in
order to have um you know uh have notes
that let us know exactly what happened
and what was asked and what was answered
and that sort of thing so we find having
you know a laptop and someone on our
committee taking those notes uh to be
kind of essential to the business uh as
well as being able to
recall so yes I recall that discussion
from last year I think we want to try to
keep that to a minimum because it is
somewhat discouraging ious to the people
sitting in the table talking to us to
see members apparently distracted by
their
computers um if you must do it to record
your notes then I'll allow it but try to
keep it
as to the minimum and I'll try try to
make it as unobtrusive as possible if
you really need to take notes about what
you heard in a public hearing you can
always go back to the YouTube recording
these meetings are being recorded and
you can go back to the YouTube meeting
uh recording and watch it and take notes
from that so it would be it would
be advantageous I think to the spirit of
listening to our constituents if we
resisted as much as possible the
temptation to use our electronic devices
while they're while they're speaking
yes uh representative uh who had their
hand up first representative Corman I
guess thank you uh so I'm one of the
people who took notes last time and I
would just like to say that in fact
rather than being distracted taking the
notes kept me Hyper focused because I
really had to pay attention to what was
going on in the questions and the
answers and I was actually extremely
attentive representative Doug Thomas
thank you Mr chair I just want to
reiterate that I think Common Sense
would rule in in this case here be aware
that we are being recorded and people do
watch us live and I've seen excerpts uh
not so much this committee but some
other committees and if someone is
watching it through you know live
streaming many times we see members and
the Committees they're like this while
someone is doing a testimony or even on
on a computer they're doing it so so
much that it looks like half the
committee members aren't being attentive
so my point is be aware that you are
being looked at and your actions are
could be viewed by the public in certain
ways that you don't intend so minimize I
think is a good key or at least uh like
in representative corman's case where
he's he's taking notes an occasional
look up and you know so people know that
you are actually looking at the public
you know would be a something good in in
my opinion so just be aware that that
you are being looked at when you're in
committee
here I think it's true that all of us
take
notes many of us use a pen and paper and
take written
notes and that I think does not offend
the public quite the way staring at a
screen does so you might want to
consider using pen and paper to take
your notes instead of an electronic
device Mr chairman
representative McGee hopefully maybe a
last point on this um you may recall I
was uh out on medical leave at the
beginning of the last term and I was
really concerned having new people
coming on the committee that they would
be able to have a central repository to
understand the work coming at them which
can sometimes be significant when you're
new it there's there's a lot so we
developed um we use technology basically
we have a Google sheet that all of our
work is centrally located in so you can
go there and look at you have links to
the bills you have the status of the
bill you have um the conversations that
happen in the hearings the votes
everything is in one place um so we are
actually leveraging technology in order
to make the work easier for everyone um
so that's the central repository where
the notes are being taken which we think
is more efficient than all of us having
stuff in individual notebooks and on
paper so we're just using technology
okay thank you speaking of a place uh
that you might want to store your
written notes uh every member will be
assigned a drawer in the filing cabinet
in the room behind us and you're welcome
to store in that drawer as much uh
material as you can get in it it's not a
huge drawer but each of us will have one
and you're welcome to use it to store
your accumulated notes and uh other
printed resources and as you will
discover new members anyway will
discover as we go through the public
hearing process you will receive a lot
of printed material from people who are
testifying before the committee and
rather than stuff that in a bag and
carry it back and forth with you to your
house you might find it advantageous to
leave that material in your drawer here
at the State House you can take it with
you if you want but you may you might
find that it's easier to to leave it
here we will have a
member uh assigned to security
notification we have not discussed that
with members yet of the committee it
will probably be a member of the
Republican caucus we will discuss uh
that at a Caucus meeting in the near
future and at one of our future meetings
I will announce who the member assigned
a security notification is that member
will be in touch with the security
services in the building and if some
kind of
security notification needs to be issued
across the building then that member
will be the first one to get that
notification and will'll pass it along
to the rest of
us it's never happened in the 10 plus
years I've been here but it is possible
that at some
point there could be either a building
problem or
a
uh problem with the public that requires
us to leave the room and or the building
and if that happens we do have a system
in place and we'll talk about that at a
future meeting so that you'll know
exactly what to H what you should do um
if you need to leave the building there
are exit signs prominently displayed
with throughout the building
and if for example a fire alarm were to
go off we should all proceed in an
orderly fashion to the nearest ex exit
and get out of the building as quickly
as
possible well we have a lot more to
cover I want representative Thomas to
talk about public hearings and
representative Bernard is going to talk
about executive her uh executive
sessions but before we get there I think
it's time now to do some introductions
so I'd like to go around the room and
have everybody introduce
themselves returning members in
reintroduce yourself to your fellow
committee members new members introduce
yourself to your fellow committee
members members say as much or as little
as you
like but uh try to give us some sense of
who you are what
your history is what your background is
what your level of interest is in the
matters that come before this
committee and uh give us a a brief
summary of why you chose to be on s&
I'll start so that that everybody can
get a sense of who I
am I'm Michael Vose I represent
Rockingham District 5 the town of
eping this is my sixth term in the house
I've served all of my terms on science
technology and energy the last three of
which I've been honored to be the chair
of this
committee I'm a New
Hampshire native although I wasn't born
here
I was born uh in Raleigh North Carolina
but my father was in the service at the
time and returned to New Hampshire after
he retired and I've lived my whole life
in New
Hampshire my family history goes back
200 years in New Hampshire to
1796 in francistown New
Hampshire I graduated from an adok
Regional High School and Keen state
colle college and the University of
Maine my undergraduate degree was in a
Bachelor of Science of History my
graduate degree is a masters of public
administration
the my work history is that I've worked
in the high technology business
virtually my entire
career computer software in particular I
was also a journalist worked for a
magazine published here in New Hampshire
called bite
magazine which was one of the first
computer magazines that covered the
personal computer magazine industry U
personal computer technology industry I
grew up with that interest industry
starting in
1983 when I joined bite magazine I had
previously worked for another technology
magazine before that
when I decided to retire from the
technology world the work a day world I
spent a couple of years doing some
freelance uh work and eventually decided
to run for the
legislature I'd actually run for the
state legislature way back in the
70s in Vermont when I lived in Vermont
and um was convinced by the local
Republican Committee in the town I lived
in to run for the state
legislature and even though I was
unsuccessful it wetted my appetite for
this kind of work and this kind of
service and so that's why I decided to
run in
2014 and um have been serving ever since
then it's been an honor and a privilege
to do
so on a personal level I enjoy hiking I
enjoy golf uh and I enjoy playing music
I play the hammer
damer I'm an off andon player of that
instrument and uh enjoy it immensely and
when it comes to listening to music I'm
a Bluegrass fan I love bluegrass music
so that's my story I'm sticking to it
and uh we'll move on by turning the M
mic over to our vice chair
representative Doug
Thomas uh thank you Mr chair well um as
you heard my name is Doug Thomas
I um I'm entering my sixth term I came
in the same time representative oose did
we served and been serving on the same
committee ever
since um my family moved to New
Hampshire when I was 9 years old so I've
been a New Hampshire resident since I
was 9 years old and I maintained that
residency throughout my 20 some odd
years in the air force uh for obvious
reasons voting and tax purposes but I
have been a New Hampshire resident ever
since then I did go to school School in
Orford New Hampshire I grew up in Orford
New Hampshire I attend school with
Governor Thompson's kids I knew Governor
Thompson at the time personally and so
to my father it was an interesting time
uh but I eventually graduated from
Handover High School uh so uh a little
bigger school and a little more
accreditation and that allowed me to
have a a better chance to enter what was
in called LEL technological Institute L
Massachusetts now UMass LEL but I
graduated there with the Bachelor of
Science and Plastics technology and
while I was in the Air Force I
eventually obtained my MBA degree from
the University of
Montana so when I I my years in the Air
Force were primarily uh as a Munitions
maintenance officer I was overseas in
Thailand during the fall of Saigon the
fall of fan pen during Miz incident
during that time period uh actually
during the Jimmy Carter Administration
and eventually got train transferred to
Spain where my son was born actually
he's a Spanish citizen uh he had to be
naturalized to come back to the States
and a few other assignments in the
states until I got out for a few years
and got a job with um down Hans Air
Force Space as a support contractor
where I eventually spent 29 years there
as a support contractor in logistics and
program management and so as I was
nearing the end of my civilian career
there I was looking for something to do
I've always been interested in uh public
affairs current events and I happen to
get a couple of good nods from people
from uh when I moved to lary I did spend
19 years living in Salem New Hampshire
uh I I'll get to in a second but uh
moved to lary met a few people that
wanted me to run for office and uh by
the grace of uh the heavens uh I won my
the last position in my primary I won
that by one vote in a recount and uh
then I went on to serve and been serving
ever since which has been a a good honor
um I will say on a on a personal scale I
spent I like I said I spent 19 years in
Salem New Hampshire I was a member of
the Salem Youth Soccer Association I
coached soccer then I became eventually
became the president of the Salem Youth
Soccer Association for several years and
I eventually moved up into the New
Hampshire soccer association where I was
the vice chair of recreation for many
years and eventually became uh one of
the few people that have become a
lifetime member of the New Hampshire
soccer association I currently sit on
the um uh occasionally on on the board
uh when they when they resolve some
disputes and complaints amongst the
coaches and uh referees so here I am and
um I uh asked for Science and Tech
because at the time I was elected I saw
that energy might be a thing up and
coming that we need to work work on and
boy was that an understatement because
that's all we do here now in this
committee virtually and so it's been
very interesting to work in this field
and to uh make sure that we um keep
having New Hampshire being the best
state that is in the in the area so I'm
glad to be here and uh welcome to talk
to anybody about any other matters
particularly travel and cruising so
that's it all right let's uh hear next
from our committee clerk JD Bernardi and
then we'll hear from ranking
member thank you Mr chair uh yes JD
Bernardi uh originally uh uh grew up in
Northwest
Minnesota uh went to the University of
Minnesota and obtained a deg Bachelor of
Science in
Biochemistry uh Navy paid for my uh
College uh I uh ended up in gron
Connecticut in the uh submarine Force um
and after about a year in uh we went to
overhaul in ports of Naval Shipyard
that's what brought me to New Hampshire
and I stayed ever since that was back in
1975 uh for those keeping count of years
um so while in the service our main
remit was uh chasing ruskies in the in
the North Atlantic um ask after uh my
tour of active duty in the uh in in
submarine Force I did another 21 years
reserve duty but I went to uh Franklin
Pierce Law Center right here which is
now UNH law uh and upon
graduation practiced uh corporate law
and eventually Regulatory and quality
assurance uh department head in seven
different pharmaceutical companies
different biotech
startups um I have four different drugs
uh with my approval on them or my hand
on in their approval I should say I was
married and had and now divorced but
have four kids um and while uh living in
Southampton uh
became uh a member of the Zoning Board
of adjustment and the last for the last
10 years I've been on that board in the
last five I've been its
chair uh upon retiring from full-time
working in the uh Pharma industry
um
uh I ran for office for the first time
so this is my third term this my second
term as Clerk of this committee and uh
hobby wise I'm uh an avid uh historian
as well as uh Gardener
horticulturist and interested in
genealogy thank you representative McGee
is next and then we'll hear from
representative
Corman thank you so much Mr chair I I
don't know where to begin I wasn't
expecting to give you my life story this
morning um I'm representative Kat McGee
I am go um entering my fourth term on
science technology and energy I serve
from Hillsboro 35 which is Hollis I
moved to Hollis for the schools in 2005
but I'll start back at the beginning um
I was a Navy brat I was born in the
Newport Naval Hospital my dad was a
20-year Navy man uh we lived in Navy
housing in Newport and when he retired
when I was 5 years old we got one move
on the service and uh my grandmother my
maternal uh my paternal grandmother
lived in Boston so we moved to Boston so
I was educated in the Boston Public
Schools I got a great education I got a
lot of opportunities um that was a time
when there were many opportunities
coming out of the they were very
creative and Innovative in the Boston
Public Schools so um I ended up in a
public um College Prep program for uh
high potential students in the city of
Boston and I got to attend UMass Boston
while I was still a
senior and then I launched from there to
school over in England cuz my mom was
British and it just happened um so I uh
was a person who worked from a very
young age so I always worked and went to
school seemed like for a very very long
time I eventually earned um a master's
of Education with an emphasis in
Psychology and um I I went I went into
business I worked in a law firm
initially while I was in grad school and
then I uh transferred over after having
um gotten married
uh to John Hancock Financial where I
spent the bulk of my career um and I I
moved around within the organization I
spent 15 years in the technology
training department which was where I
started managing enterprise-wide
projects for the technology Workforce
and for the company as a whole in terms
of training so that was really a a
Proving Ground where I started learning
skills that were more applicable to the
21st century so I was lucky that I made
that leap um from business skills over
to the technology world and an
understanding of Technology um I uh I
was also divorced I had one child at the
time I was on my own for a while um and
that was
fine uh but then I I met my current
husband 20 25 years ago and um because
I'm old and and uh we've been married
for 20 years um he had three children so
we have three grown children between
four grown children between us and nine
grandchildren and one
great-grandchild um when I moved up to
Hollis New Hampshire one of the things
that happened early on after um I took a
job at skillsoft as in the program
office as a program manager for software
engineering globally had a number of
International Teams there was there for
seven years and then my husband sold
this company and he invited me to no
longer work for the man he said if you
want to go do some work that you would
like to do um you know you can do that
so that is what I did um it took a
little while to figure out what I wanted
to do and um I first ran in 2012 I ran
in 2014 and 2016
unsuccessfully um and in that time there
was a um pipeline project that was
coming through Northern Mass with a Spur
through that was going to bifurcate my
town and of course many people that had
received notes saying their land was
going to be affected were upset about
that and I stepped forward to try and
get more informed on that issue and I
ended up uh being asked by the town to
chair a task force to look at the rsas
that could potentially act as uh
protections for the town so that turned
into a wonderful project with a bunch of
great people um which uh towards the end
of us working a number of different
angles on trying to interact with the
state uh resulted in a change in the
plan where our Hollis was no longer part
of the plan they they moved up into
Southern New Hampshire and were
affecting then 17 towns uh but skirting
ours and so uh I moved on to the
Nashville Regional planning commission's
energy facility advisory committee and
as um I don't know if Mike lot is still
here at the time he was with Liberty
that's the first time I got to know him
in a room but um um I I started to study
the regional energy landscape and my
connection in wanting to be on this
committee is that I understood that
energy is complex and the ability to
speak about it clearly and um also make
sure that we made good decisions because
they can be very costly decisions if we
don't make good decisions um that was
the work that I wanted to do and that's
the work I've been attempting to do
since I've been
here thank you representative Corman is
up next then representative n thank you
Mr chairman Tom Corman I represent
Grafton 15 which is Ward three of the
city of Lebanon uh this is my second
term in the house I'm serving as the
deputy ranking member on this committee
I grew up in Oceanside New York went to
Oceanside High School got a BSE in
electrical engineering and computer
science from Princeton and then an SM
and PhD in the same from MIT
while I was at MIT I got involved in a
project of writing a textbook with two
MIT professors one of whom is uh
actually a turing Award winner which is
like the Nobel of computer science uh
this book is called introduction to
algorithms it's currently in its fourth
edition and has sold over a million
copies worldwide so that's been pretty
cool and actually a fun fact because of
the book I was actually once a clue on
Jeopardy
uh a a after escaping from MIT after
eight years um I got a job at Dartmouth
as a computer science Professor moved to
the Upper Valley in 1992 and Lebanon in
1993 with my wife
Nicole and uh Rose through the ranks
became a full Professor I was that rare
full Professor who actually wanted to
teach the introductory courses and I
loved teaching the introductory courses
I'm still friends with many of the
students who took those courses from me
many of whom were not ultimately
computer science Majors but I just got
to be friends with them um uh I also
directed The Dartmouth College writing
program for the first four years of the
program so I have very strong views on
writing um I retired from Dartmouth
three years ago I was working with a
nonprofit in um White River Junction
called cover home repair and and there
was an opening uh for the house in
Lebanon ward 3 Senator Su Prentice
recruited me I ran and I won and now I'm
in my second term um unfortunately my
wife passed away in
2015 and she really uh she did a lot for
the city of Lebanon serving on various
committees and seven years on the city
council and she really inspired my
interest in doing public service so once
I was recruited it I decided yes this is
something I want to do uh with my tech
background I thought I'd be a natural
fit for this committee little did I
realize that this is really the energy
energy and energy committee so I've had
to learn a lot about energy which I
really enjoyed doing and I know I've
made progress because I went from I
don't know what I don't know to now I
know what I don't
know thank you representative next up is
representative Janine ner and after that
we will representative Michael
Harrington who is also a member of this
committee and a senior member of this
committee is not here he's actually on
vacation nobody should feel sorry for
him um but after that we'll go to I
think uh representative
parall thank you Mr chairman um my name
is Janine I'm from California originally
I'm the youngest of six kids and then I
have six kids so I've been busy very
busy life um got got married in 1985 and
we moved here in 1998 so
after thinking about that I guess I I'll
have to say we were five at the time
five years old just to do the
math um I first ran for office in 2010
when Governor sonunu the dad asked me to
run and I like me run like okay um I was
the majority whip for two terms prior to
that I did the same job but had a
different title I was Deputy Republican
floor leader this term I'm the assistant
Majority Leader it's a new job and a lot
more work looking forward to it though
keeps me very busy um I'm the task force
chair for communications and Technology
with the American legislators exchange
Council so we do a lot with um with
tech uh don't understand all of it but
it's okay because when you're running a
meeting you don't really have to know
you just have to know how to how to run
a meeting and we'll hear from you we
hear from you
which you know well um I don't really
like to talk too much about myself so
um I run 12 marathons and 13 half
marathons officially did a lot of
unofficial marathons but I don't didn't
get medals for those I'm a history geek
and I have lots of hobbies but I my
favorite thing in the world are the four
little grandbabies that we have that are
ages three and
under that's a wonderful thing to be
proud of all right representative
partials up next and then we'll have
representative
PL yes I'm Lucius parall from marbor New
Hampshire um it's my third term here I
moved up here about 30 years ago a
prisoner of Love uh since then we had uh
we've raised two semi- adult
children um my degrees uh I have a uh
degree in audio engineering a couple
degrees in music uh and Masters in
Business from Sunni Bingington most of
my life was spent in New York State uh
part of that in New York City where I
worked in uh Arts
Administration uh for the last 20 years
I've been a music teacher uh and
teaching in public school and being
around young children is
just probably the best thing I ever did
in my life um being around with people
that th listened and not didn't actually
listen to respond or to you know listen
out of curiosity all the things that I
truly value
myself um and so after upon after uh
retiring in 2020 I figure the best way I
could continue my commitment to them
would be to serve in public office and
uh climate change is one of my large
concerns that's what brings me
here um I say uh I cook for
relaxation I play guitar U very I Styles
I just joined a jazz guitar Ensemble um
I have host a monthly SE Shanty sing
that was my taster
verse and um I guess when it comes to
listening uh my uh preference would
probably uh be as my students used to
say listen to music by dead people so uh
uh I guess that you know classics the
classics so I guess that covers it thank
you thank you representative PL up next
and then representative Wendy Thomas
after that uh thank you yes Tom P
represent bellnap one that's New Hampton
and sener harbor um came up to New
Hampshire backpacking in my 20s and
teens atex also and in h the Green
Mountains in Vermont so upper New
England was where I spent my youth spare
time um I raised four kids retired early
so retired to New Hampshire in
2008 um I've been a EMT well Ems for 43
years till I aged
out and um that was
volunteer and I was asked to run to fill
in a a vacant seat and I've been here in
Science and Tech also for three terms
thank
you okay up next is Wendy Thomas
followed by by representative Summers
thank you um I am Wendy Thomas uh no
relation to Doug Thomas we'll just get
that right out there right now
um um I represent the town of marac
which is Hillsboro 12 um I've raised all
six of my children in marac and this is
my third term my first term I was on
resources and the last term I was on
this committee and I continue being on
this
committee um just an interesting point
of fact because a lot of people are
talking about genealogy a member of my
family assassinated Alexander Hamilton
to which we still
apologize uh my work experience I
started off as a clinical
microbiologist um and then I moved to
installing computer systems in hospitals
then I moved up to New Hampshire became
a tech writer moved into course
developer and ultimately worked as an
instructional designer for digital
Equipment Corporation HP and compact
um I have also worked as a journalist
and I have taught undergraduate and
graduate classes in writing and
professional writing and I am a BPI
certified building analyst so the areas
that I tend to concentrate in our P I'm
one of the water Warriors out of marac
that has been fighting our P problem
from uh an industrial polluter s Cain uh
cannabis Renewables climate and Health
Care thank
you okay representative Summers up next
and then representative
rolds good morning everybody I'm uh Dr
James Summers just call me Jim um I
represent Rockingham District 20 that is
plastow Newton and Southampton um this
is my third term at the house and I've
spent all three terms here on Science
Tech and energy uh non-c concurrently uh
2010 to 2012 is my first one
um I moved up here from Texas in in 25
years ago so every once in a while
you'll hear a y'all are all y'all and
that's that's just me still and never
will lose it um as far as uh my job I've
spent the last 30 years in the it sector
um last six I've uh founded and CEO of
my own it network engineering company um
and uh
educationwise uh so I have a um I got my
doctorate from Liberty University I'm
currently halfway through and I'll
actually finish this may with my uh
jurist master in American legal studies
and constitutional law from Liberty as
well um I have my corporate Innovation
degree master's degree from Penn State
University and a grad certificate from
MIT and cyber security um so with my uh
background I found important for this
committee a for it
telecommunications but also um before
all the schooling I spent 5 years in the
military as a nuclear engineer on
submarines so uh nuclear energy
especially small scale nuclear energy is
important to me and uh my hobbies um
currently I have little time I I coached
football for 25 years um here in New
Hampshire middle school and high school
um around the state and um I golf when I
can I'm also at Professor for Liberty
University and B Haven University and
this is me my first year as a doctoral
chair there as well that's it thank you
thank you representative reyolds is up
next and then we'll have representative
bney who I lost track of because he's
way down
there all right thank you Mr chairman uh
I'm Ned rolds I represent uh Portsmouth
uh rocking seat is Rockingham 3 n of
flal District so I represent three-
fifths of the city of Portsmouth um I
moved to Portsmouth in in
2001 um and and got involved in in local
Affairs pretty quickly and ended up
serving a few terms on the city
council uh but I'm not so obviously not
from Portsmouth I grew up in Western
Massachusetts West Springfield um
from there I went to the uh US Coast
Guard Academy uh where I graduated uh
from in
1986 uh my degree Bachelor's in
government so uh anyway graduated went
to a ship in Portland out of Portland
Maine for two years from there
Washington DC where I was on the uh
Congressional Affairs staff at the time
of the Exxon Valdes
I was deployed to the scene of the Exxon
Valdes um and that made a big impression
on me and uh so after one more turn uh
one more uh active duty uh station out
in San Francisco doing uh work on oil
spill prevention and response
preparedness um I left active duty
stayed in the Coast Guard Reserves but
went to uh the now it's called The
Harvard Kennedy School of government and
got a MERS in public
policy and from there started a 25-year
career in the field of Energy Efficiency
and renewable energy uh first working
for uh I was hired by the Lawrence
berley lab but to be embedded at uh the
EPA in Washington working on the energy
star program when it was uh almost brand
new back in
1996 um and after five years there in in
DC H having got married and now had uh
on the verge of our second child
arriving we took a chance to come back
for me back to New England uh and that's
when I moved to Portsmouth uh worked
for a few environmental energy nonprofit
organizations and succession including
um the union of concerned scientists
where I worked I was the Northeast
climate policy coordinator and worked on
uh getting the northeast states to adopt
and then properly Implement Reggie the
regional greenhouse gas
initiative
um and then in um 2011 well I did a
little stint uh in between the nonprofit
sector uh with my growing family needing
to make a little more money so tried to
transition over to the business side of
things uh but did worked for about year
and a half with
Unitil uh but then uh was hired by
Johnson Controls and worked um deploying
multifaceted Energy Efficiency and
renewable energy projects for school
districts and uh municipalities and
counties including marrat County where
we helped convert uh the boiler system
up in bosow into uh wood chips and did a
lot of Energy Efficiency work and all
the
buildings um and then
um after Johnson Controls worked three
and a half years for revision energy um
uh as a commercial sales commercial uh
solar systems so I'm a big believer in
obviously Energy Efficiency and solar uh
Renewable Energy Technologies so obvious
choice um my choice was this committee
um but I no longer do that work um since
um deciding to run for the legislature
um I now own and operate in my spare
time a u bicycle touring company running
uh multi-day bike tours in places around
the country I have a group down in Key
Florida Keys right now where I wish I
was but I'm not uh and that's so that's
me I have those three children and uh I
guess my hobbies um I like to swim and
bike and run so occasionally I do a
little triath line just to put them all
together just a little Sprint Triathlon
um every now and then I I play um men's
league hockey and and the winner and
men's league baseball in the summer and
do a little
woodworking
yeah okay thank you next up is
representative grne followed by
representative Kaplan
I'm representative Lex bney I represent
Grafton District 11 which is the towns
of uh Grafton Alexandria Hein and Groton
um I moved up to I I was born in Ukraine
and I my parents immigrated with me to
the US when I was seven um I finished
Middle School and High School in
Arlington
Virginia uh when I was in high school I
started working uh in the software
industry um and actually my uh senior
year of high school
uh was when the 911 happened and one of
our biggest contractors where I was at
the company I was working was in one of
the towers so a week after that I lost
my job and then it was just just school
after that um uh then I got hired at a
different company also in Arington
Virginia where I worked for 10 years uh
working on projects for usaid I worked
on a project management system and then
a credit management system uh for USA uh
in 2006 I moved to Grafton where I've
lived ever since then um I joined the
fire department in 2007 I've been on the
department since then currently uh
serving as secretary uh I have two
daughters um uh this is my third term
and also my third uh third uh term on
this
committee um and when I originally was
looking through the committee list of
which committee to join this one had
technology in it and I thought that well
maybe I have some relevant uh background
on that I quickly learned that it was as
representative Corman said it's energy
energy and energy uh and that's it for
me representative capin is next and then
we'll start with our new members start
with representative
Matson yeah hi good morning uh
representative Tony Kaplan representing
maram ma 8 the towns of hener Bradford
and Warner uh sorry I was a little bit
late chair uh but uh here I am so I was
born in uh Venezuela actually in uh to
American parents uh working over es uh
grew up there till I was about 12 went
to high school in Connecticut graduated
from Yale with the Bachelor's in
American studies uh I went into
journalism at that point I worked for
wire Services United Press International
in Mexico City Central America uh the
Associated Press in London on the
financial desk um at some point my wife
and I decided to transition our careers
and uh I went into nonprofit activism I
was the climate change uh and Atmos
climate change uh campaigner for friends
of the earth Ireland for about three
years uh we managed to change the
trajectory of that uh country's um
climate change plans and get them more
in line with uh trying to make a clean
energy transition instead of trying to
grow their uh carbon dioxide emissions
which they were allowed to do Under the
EU rules at that point because they were
one of the poorer uh countries in Europe
uh uh we came back to the States my wife
and I in 198
1990 and uh
I got a job as a public school teacher I
taught uh High School
Spanish for about 20 years uh also got
involved with the hker energy Committee
in my town and uh started that up in
2006 did the hker energy committee for a
number of years got involved with the
Haner Democratic committee uh and then
was asked to run for uh for office as a
state representative uh which I was
happy to do and uh wanted to serve on
the science technology and energy
committee because of my background
around with uh energy issues and uh so
that's about it for me happy to be here
my going on my third term thank you
representative Kaplan for those of you
sitting in the audience and watching at
home we have a presentation scheduled by
the department of energy it will it was
originally scheduled to start at 10:00
we're running a few minutes late here I
just want everybody to know that we'll
start as soon as we finish our committee
introductions next up is representative
Matson a new member of the committee and
that will be followed by representative
La
relle thank you Mr chairman um my name
is Rita Matson I live in Dublin um I've
been in New Hampshire for 61 years so
far I'm planning on staying here
forever um my introduction to my career
path was in junior high school when I
had an argument with the powers that be
that girls female can also take shop my
argument was the guys can take homec I
can take shop and so I was the first
female to have the shop class and it
started me on my path um I've been a
plumber I've been a builder my favorite
is my industrial mechanic background and
um my husband and my son both worked for
well my husband's retired for ever
source which is my interest in the
energy field um I know a lot about
transmission stuff all you know all the
powers that
um how they maintain lines and I have a
good grip on it so that's why my ENT the
this committee would is my
choice um so my hobbies I like riding
motorcycles I build doll houses I paint
um I have one
daughter and two grandchildren and
that's about it oh I live in
Dublin thank you next we're here from
representative lar roelle followed by
representative schel
shellner uh thank you Mr chair I'm John
larell and I represent straford 19 which
is 56 of Rochester uh I was actually
born and raised in Rochester as my
parents were um I got my undergraduate
degree in chemistry from the University
of New Hampshire um I started my
graduate degree at Iowa State University
in analytical chemistry but that was
interrupted by being drafted
uh so I got to be a combat infantryman
with specialty in jungle warfare but
fortunately I was sent to Germany uh
after that two years stent I went back
and got my graduate degree at at State
University uh I spent four years
teaching at small colleges at Hamilton
University for one year St John's
University U for three years discovered
I couldn't really raise a family on that
pay so I joined the DuPont company and
worked for Dupont for 20 years till I
downsized me uh mainly working in the
support uh of Discovery registration and
manufacturing of
pesticides um I was downsized and was
living in Delaware I have three children
from my first wife were're
divorced and I came back to Rochester to
marry my second wife uh
Gloria who unfortunately passed away 11
years
ago um so I I became interested in
public service because I felt so
fortunate to grow up in Rochester with a
sound education and a safe environment I
felt
privileged and so I became interested in
public service and that's one of my
interests and I've been a science geek
since third grade so Science and
Technology are a continuing in interest
I've discovered a love of history and
so um I applied for this committee and I
feel fortunate I got here and I'm
looking forward to learning a lot from
you all thank
you thank you and welcome representative
schneller is up next it's going to take
me a while to get that
right red red light thank you Mr
chairman and members of the
committee uh my name is John scheller
I'm from Bedford represent Bedford um
I've served on the school board in
Bedford also on the Town Council was
asked to run for State Rep a number of
times this time was
successful um and uh happy to serve as
the chairman pointed out I'm a freshman
100% of my legislative career has been
spent on this committee all of a month
um and I've enjoyed every minute of it
so far
um let's see I have a a went to high
school in Massachusetts I have a ba in
history from UMass Amherst and mson
public administration from suffk
University in Boston and an MBA from
Cornell uh the vast majority of my
career was on Wall Street um but over
the past 10 or 12 years I've served as
uh Chief Financial Officer of technology
companies uh Healthcare tech company I'm
presently the CFO and a partner at a uh
emerging Growth fintech Company um so
I'm heavily involved in technology where
we try and improve liquidity Solutions
of midsize
businesses uh across the um uh
usmca Alliance uh trade Alliance
um personally uh so I also publish an
agricultural technology piece by monthly
and there's a fairly strong convergence
between Agriculture and energy so that's
where I develop my interest in energy
and uh look forward to uh immersing
myself in that uh personally I
uh uh still serve or work with the
Bedford men's club so I tell my
constituents if if I haven't sold you a
Christmas tree I've cooked you a
hamburger um and that that's been very
enjoyable I also uh have been a lacrosse
coach at Bishop girton still am and uh
have done that for the past four or five
years uh played across my whole life and
and love that sport
um that's pretty much my background and
I appreciate it and look forward to
serving thank you thank you before we
get to our last new member I'll
apologize to the Department of energy
for not starting you guys right at 10:00
but offer you the opportunity to come up
if you have any slides to show us and
connect to the um audiovisual system
while we hear from the final new
representative
representative Swanson and welcome to
the committee and looking forward to
meeting
you thank you Mr chairman Dale Swanson
uh Nashville award one just south of
nashwa
airport uh as mentioned it this is my
first term it is uh kind of exciting to
be here and uh uh you may hear me repeat
that very often and uh try to keep the
the positive Buzz going I grew up in
Minnesota and uh I always wanted to fly
and so uh I worked hard in high school
and uh worked at a job and got my
pilot's license at the age of 18 just
before going off to school and uh I
applied to the Air Force Academy I also
applied to the Coast Guard Academy which
rejected me uh but did get into the Air
Force Academy they would take my
eyesight uh I was qualified to be a
navigator so I gradu ated from the Air
Force Academy with a degree in
astronautical
engineering and uh then went into the
Air Force operationally and got
qualified in the right seat of the F-111
swing-wing
fighter excuse me uh spent uh six years
in England operationally flying around
uh the countries of NATO and uh a very
exciting time when East Germany and East
Berlin still existed and there were
people trying to shoot you down if you
came too close and uh uh moved on to uh
the electronic warfare f11 and moved
went to Idaho and uh then uh got
transferred to the stealth fighter
program in uh Nevada and deployed
shortly after that to Saudi Arabia in
support of Desert Storm in 1990 actually
it was Desert Shield then Desert Storm
and I planned missions for the stealth
fighter during that time frame I was
there I returned to State Side from 91
to 93 uh worked as a test director for
that program the stealth fighter program
in the ranges of uh the western United
States uh but got out of the Air Force
in
1993 and uh joined uh uh a company a
tech company um down in Bedford
Massachusetts and worked there uh I
should note that I always had a passion
for computers and got my masters in
computer
science uh in about it was
1995 and uh became a systems engineer on
Mission planning systems for uh
supporting the air force uh for the
miner Corporation and then uh moved over
to weather systems and then over to uh
uh became a a project uh uh manager and
uh a miter project leader and also came
to uh lead a group of Engineers excuse
me on uh Air Force weather systems uh
that was my latest job with uh them in
Massachusetts and uh but decided it was
time to retire after uh uh more than two
decades with them and uh I was living we
were living in Maryland at the time we
had spent 18 years in Hudson New
Hampshire uh had moved to Maryland for
11 years and wanted to come back to New
England because of the children uh two
of our sons and their families and our
four grandchildren were living in this
area so uh we decided we would really
like to get back here but uh um now that
we moved here uh decided that uh even
though I've told people I don't have
time to work I'm retired
I have uh you know uh wanted I decided I
would run for election and some people
encourag me and this has been a great
experience and uh uh I'm doing a lot of
things I love and and a new community
that I'm really enjoying is the
community of people who are in in
service of the state in public service
and that is uh even though I was in the
military I didn't feel that well
connected with the citizens or directly
with the public so uh uh this has been a
great experience I love the things I can
do around here I like scuba diving when
I can but a lot of bicycling uh swimming
and uh running uh with the kids my
oldest grandson now is getting into
cross country so uh that is uh really
exciting right there so uh it's great to
be here thank you very much for your
time and thank you and welcome to the
committee you'll want to touch base
representative Harrington when he
returns from vacation he's probably
scuba diving right
now all right well thank you all
for uh the
introductions did you have something
representative paral very quick question
for our vice chair who was going to
speak about technology a little bit I
liked your common sense approach we are
going to turn cell phones off as well
right I highly recommend you turn cell
phones off yes
thank you well that's why they have a
silent mod but the visual works if you
need to really see something of
importance um okay and I'm I might add
um uh for those to clarify uh
representative Thomas Vice chair Thomas
um any confusion I am the taller
one yes we'll keep that I'm a little
cuter though we'll keep both of those
ideas
close to our chest here all right I'd
like to invite the department of energy
to come forward to give us a
presentation the next two hours we will
devote to the department if necessary
they're going to give us a presentation
first and then we will um open the floor
to the committee to ask questions of the
committee before they start two more
housekeeping
things the seating arrangement for this
morning's meeting was kind of uh
impromptu I have not had a chance to
work with the ranking member to see if
this is the final seating arrangement we
want or not if anybody has any issues
please talk to your caucus leader and
we'll dis discuss whether or not to make
any seating changes the last important
piece of information for all committee
members is if you want to know what's
happening with this committee consult
the house calendar on a regular basis
either weekly or daily all meetings that
we hold for this committee will be
scheduled in the house
calendar and with that I'd now like to
welcome the commissioner and Deputy
Commissioner of the Department of energy
to tell us what is it the heck that you
guys
do great well thank you Mr chairman uh
members of the committee for the
opportunity to present today uh my name
is Jared chakin I'm the commissioner of
the New Hampshire Department of energy
and I'm joined today by Deputy
Commissioner Chris Elms um you know in
past years we've had the opportunity to
present and uh it's been pretty lengthy
presentations I think at one point maybe
last time at the beginning of the new
term we took up about half a day um but
the chairman has asked us to sort of
move things along and maybe a little
more of a high level uh presentation for
you today with that said though if there
are particular topics um of interest to
you as an individual maybe groups of the
committee we'd be happy to meet with you
separately and and talk about those and
bring in the appropriate staff um to
disc discuss those issues so please
don't feel like today is your only
opportunity we'd love to meet with all
of you um if that's what you'd like and
uh and go through that and and if you
would like that opportunity Meg Stone um
who's with us
today and I think some of you may know
Meg from her time working here at the
house um Meg um oh do we need something
yeah is there another copy of the
presentation material there should be a
copy
for yes I think we brought plenty thank
you
that that's Meg for everybody if you
don't know
her and please reach out to Meg if you'd
like to meet with us on any particular
issue um we can get that scheduled and
and also I would add that uh if you're
new to the committee um we typically uh
the department will send staff to most
hearings if if not all uh so you see us
here will be a present um and able to
answer questions uh when they when they
arise uh so let's get to it um so so
slide two uh the department of energy is
one of the newest State agencies um I
was corrected recently that we're not
the newest I've been saying that for a
while um but uh I think we're the newest
commissioner Le state agency um
commissioner Arling house corrected me
on that recently so I just want to be
clear we're one of the newest agencies
and and probably the only the newest
agency led by a commissioner um we were
created in the budget in 2021 and and
what that did is it uh created the
department
um as part of that the office of
strategic initiatives which was the
governor's Energy Office was dissolved
um those functions came to the new
Department um the Pu um still exists uh
as a much smaller entity that's focused
on their role as adjudicators of utility
rate matters and um the doe was created
in part for greater executive branch
input into energy policy um while
allowing the Pu to remain um independent
we have about 78 full employees um about
another dozen or so that are uh
full-time temporary or or part-time
employees so about 90 total um despite
our relatively small size we have a big
and diverse Mission as you'll see um
we'll discuss some of that here in a bit
um and you can also see on slide two our
mission statement if that's helpful uh
moving on to slide
three uh the department of agency uh
Department of energy has two two
agencies administratively attached to it
the Public Utilities Commission and the
office of the consumer Advocate um the
state's site evaluation committee is
attached to the P to the Pu so um kind
of like one of those Russian nesting
dolls um so the administrative
attachment really only applies to back
office functions such as helping to
manage the agency budgets and things
like that we don't get involved in their
decisionmaking in any way um we just are
there to help them um with sort of the
administrative um support that they need
um the department of energy consists of
the commissioner's office and four
divisions um policy the policy and
program division is led by Josh Elliott
who's here today you'll hear from him in
a little bit as uh I believe you've
asked for a deeper dive into the RPS so
you'll hear from Josh soon um the doe
has a statutory role as a policy agency
and is uh directed to maintain New
Hampshire's 10-year State energy
strategy uh the department is also
active at the legislature to provide
technical support as well as to provide
the executive branch perspective on
legislation uh as directed by the
governor Doe's consumer services team
helps mediate disputes between consumers
and utility companies um and I would
just add here that if you have a
constituent who needs um uh support with
an issue with utility please send them
our way uh our team is happy to help um
we oversee Assistance programs like the
fuel assistance program the electric
assistance program um um and the gas
program and weatherization assistance
program um we have grants and uh grants
and rebates team with staff who manage
programs associated with Federal funding
and state renewable energy funds the
division also oversees the office of
offshore wind development and energy
Innovation uh we have an enforcement
division which is led by our director
Mike Susi um who is recently confirmed
to that position uh doe enforces federal
and state laws related to utility
pipeline safety electrical safety
underground damage prevention you might
know as digsafe um enforcement includes
uh Doe's utility Auditors who check the
reliability of utility books records and
filings and their role is very important
for instance in a rate utility rate case
in developing uh our position um due
monitors and enforces compliance with
sighting certificates issued by the SEC
um and the staff is also dedicated to
reviewing the utilities cyber security
plans um doe is often called upon to
assist in state emergency preparedness
and response related to energy issues so
if there's a major winter storm where
there are many thousands of outages
Statewide um members of our team will go
to the emergency Operation Center um and
and assist um the Homeland Security
emergency man Emergency Management um
agency with their role during uh those
um storms
um our regulatory division is led by uh
director Amanda Nunan who's here today
um the regulatory team reviews and
analyzes utility filings before the Pu
helps build the record on which the Pu
makes decisions uh and advocates for the
public interest and makes
recommendations to the Pu um regulated
entities at the Pu broadly fall into
three Industries electric gas water and
sewer the regulatory division also has a
unit focused on sustainability uh who in
addition to analytical work administer
our state's renewable portfolio standard
uh and our group net metering
program doe regulatory staff are
generally assigned to one industry
although there's often crossover on
dockets among staff outside of pu
dockets regulatory analysts are heavily
involved in due
proceedings investigations rulemakings
Etc and often provide expert level
support uh to other staff such as those
working with legislators there's a lot
of work to go around for a very small
team we have a division of
administration which is led by director
Rory Patterson and that includes staff
who primarily support other teams within
the department and includes the business
office and Doe's regulatory attorneys um
business office functions include
managing the agency budget preparing and
collecting the utility assessment and
providing Operational Support to Doe
staff uh as well as the attached
agencies division staff lead on state
Contracting uh on the state Contracting
process as well as assisting with
financial management and compliance with
Federal programs doe attorneys primarily
work with regulatory staff in
adjudicated pu proceedings and conduct
do uh doe
proceedings uh in in addition to the
above uh division specific roles we have
the responsibility to represent New
Hampshire in Regional electricity issues
as a representative at the New England
states committee on electricity the
department is active in discussion and
negotiation at the regional level uh and
as you'll hear later uh we have a very
different perspective than our neighbors
we're also often tasked by the
legislature and the governor with
projects investigations and proceedings
uh we'll talk a little bit more about
that shortly um slide
four I know we said we're going to keep
things high level uh but we do want to
touch on just a couple of educational
pieces that I think would be helpful a
lot of what we're going to discuss in
the next few slides will be in the
context of electricity which tends to be
the most prevalent um and has been one
of the most interest of the most
interest in the
legislature um here's a diagram um that
uh ISO New England has used to give a
high Lev perspective on the electricity
grid again this is high level I know
you're hearing from ISO New England
maybe tomorrow um or the next day um so
we won't get too much into this but uh
as you can see we have generators uh
transmission infrastructure and
distribution infrastructure that is
necessary to produce and deliver
electricity uh to the homes of
consumers um slide
five uh this slide essentially says what
um goes into an electric bill uh and
provides a high level information on the
types of costs that Rays have to pay uh
have to pay for and where those costs
are created and
regulated distribution costs for
customers of New Hampshire's
investor-owned utilities are regulated
by the Pu
uh utilities seek to recover their costs
and reasonable Returns on their
investment through electric rates those
rates are reviewed by the department of
energy and the OCA who make
recommendations to the Pu who has to
determine whether the rates are just
reasonable and in the public
interest transmission costs are
regulated by the Federal Energy
Regulatory Commission um the department
uh weighs in mostly through the New
England states committee on electricity
uh in Regional discussions um in issues
before
FK Supply costs are associated with the
purchase of electricity that consumers
use with the deregulation of New
Hampshire's electricity Market utilities
cannot profit off of supply and
customers have the option to use other
suppliers utilities provide the default
Service Supply um which what other
states call Last Resort service or basic
service the Pu sets the framework for
utilities to procure default service and
their solicitations are reviewed by the
DOE and then finally there are costs
paid by rate payers that are not those
that are strictly necessary for the
provision of electric service um these
can be wide ranging uh from things like
Energy effic Efficiency to renewable
subsidies to the electric assistance
program public policy costs are
currently a huge topic of conversation
in Connecticut where they've seen high
costs associated with their nuclear
purchase power agreements uh offshore
wind and other things like a moratorium
on utility
disconnections uh next slide slide
this slide looks at the various costs
you might see on your electric bill as
an eversource customer um it really it's
really just to give you a nice visual
representation of the various charges uh
and costs that customers are responsible
for and then moving on to slide
seven uh this slide looks at a
comparison of electric of electric rates
uh we're looking at eversource rates for
the states where eversource does
business um as a nice comparison um okay
at this point I'll turn it over to
Deputy Commissioner
Els uh thank you uh Mr chairman members
of the committee it's uh really great to
see a lot of you and nice to meet some
of you um I know we have uh not a lot of
time so I'll just go through this uh as
as quickly as I can we did select some
sort of pu proceedings just to kind of
give you a you know a view on some of
the complex and uh you know diverse
responsibilities that our regulatory
folks have I'll admit sort of my uh my
goal here is just to show you know a lot
of the things we have on our plate with
a with a small staff and just you know
as a as a helpful context as you guys
are considering legislation we hope
you'll consider um you know sort of what
goes into administering and
investigating a lot of those things
because you know frankly we're all
always willing to uh look into something
with with Direction but we do have to
prioritize based on the resources that
we have available to us so uh you know
here are a list of some of the high
important um high level important
proceedings you know rate cases tend to
be the really the the bread and butter
of what you know our regulatory division
are looking at that's how we're you know
looking at those uh you know broad-based
distribution rates that folks are going
to be be uh paying um we've also been
given responsibility by the governor and
by by the legislature uh a number of
Investigations proceedings and projects
um and and and I think some of you are
familiar and have seen uh bills related
to these Topics in previous legislative
sessions Jared did touch on many of the
responsibilities of the policy and
programs uh division uh here are some of
them I just wanted you to have uh
something you know down it tends to be
the division where we hear a lot uh from
legislators oftentimes uh in a policy
context and and in other cases through
constituent inquiries or anything like
that um so here are just some of the
things that we're working on if that
helps uh look towards uh questions uh at
the end of this presentation
um where I wanted to spend most of my
time was on Regional electric issues uh
because that is an area that doesn't
come up as much in legislation do in
large part to where the regulatory UH
responsibilities lie but it does provide
important context I think to you as as
legislators as you're you're making uh
you know your policy decisions uh when
it comes to
electricity so as as as many of us know
uh New Hampshire is part of the grid
that's uh operated by ISO New England um
we are a small part of that grid about
10% of the of the regional load uh is
the responsibility of New Hampshire
because we're such a small part of that
load we uh have to work closely with our
neighbors uh and a lot of that involves
um you know uh cooperation negotiation
collaboration and and sometimes
disagreement uh and maybe sometimes as
an understatement um you know we do
share a lot of Dynamics with our
neighbors but those differences uh
really come about when you're looking at
a lot of the public policy decisions
that we have to make um all of our
neighbors uh in New England are are very
focused on decarbonization on on
prioritizing lower zero carbon resources
uh and their goal is to influence our
resource mix to reflect uh their goals
uh New Hampshire's policy positioning
has been uh to prioritize costs and
reliability we don't have
decarbonization goals in New Hampshire
and uh so that leads to circumstances
where sometimes our goals are not
aligned uh with the rest of the region
the New Hampshire legislature has
charged the department of energy uh in
our regional discussions with uh here uh
let's see the the the responsibility to
guard against the cost shifting of other
states policies to our Rays I didn't
have the exact statuto language down
here but uh you can see it in RSA
374f 8 um you know our Focus has been on
on market efficiency uh technology
neutrality reliability and affordability
and you'll see those goals reflected in
the current iteration of our tene state
energy
strategy uh this slide just illustrates
some of the uh clean energy goals that
um our our neighbors have it might be a
little out of date I think with with a
state or two I can't remember this
reflects vermonts recent changes uh but
if you look at these and you say well
well gez these must be hard goals to to
meet uh you're
right um and and I know you're going to
hear from ISO England I don't know
they're going to uh bring this up but
they recently released a document called
economic planning for the clean energy
transition and this is a report that's
designed to look at the statutory clean
energy goals of the New England states
and try to Envision this system that's
going to be necessary to meet those
goals by
2050 and and what they found it doesn't
give me a warm fuzzy feeling I don't I
don't know how it'll land with you uh
but but really what the report says that
is that if it's possible to meet these
goals it's going to be expensive it's
going to be incredibly inefficient and
uh there are going to be difficulties
associated with meeting our reliability
uh needs so to give you an example of
the scale of of the issue and sort of
the inefficiency that we're facing
results of the modeling in the report
show that the New England system uh if
we're going to continue uh on a strategy
that relies on wind solar and batteries
uh is going to need 97 gaw of total new
renewable capacity by 2050 to achieve
our state goals uh that's about 18 times
the current combined capacity of wind
solar and batteries that we have on the
system today and we're going to have to
achieve that in 25 years so because of
seasonal and weather related variations
under this modeling in 2045 a new
resource would be expected to run less
than 10% of the year the report states
that quote some resources needed to
maintain reliability during the harshest
conditions may only run once every few
years the report points to a wide
variation in what's going to be needed
for reliability between mild and uh
harsh uh winter conditions uh so we're
talking about in having to build out
several gws of electricity that will
never run in most W winter conditions or
will run fewer than 1% of the hours of
the year so there are a lot of people
who are working really really hard on
these issues I don't want to be too too
dire um looking at these things but but
there are concerns looking forward we we
do spend a lot of time analyzing these
issues uh working with our neighbors um
but I hope it I hope you take from it
some of the context that we're looking
at regionally because you know I think
New Hampshire has taken a goals oriented
uh policy approach that that I think is
uh beneficial to our positioning uh
regionally and we hope you continue uh
on that
trajectory um on the Regional
discussions it's worth touching on
transmission costs which represent a
very significant part of the bill about
30% of wholesale Market costs uh
specifically I want to talk about a
class of projects called asset
conditioning projects um I think many of
you folks uh may have had discussions
and meetings about this topic but uh
asset condition projects are those that
are nominally meant to replace old
obsolete or damaged infrastructure and
obviously that's an important function
right and maintaining our reliability is
is priority number one but the issue is
that the spending on these projects is
basically free of regulatory
oversight the spending has been
substantial and there are real questions
as to whether or not they are necessary
to the extent that they are they have
been undertaken or plann to be
undertaken and so this is a tremendous
amount of money New Hampshire rays are
going to be on the hook for about 10% of
the 5.4 billion dollar in spending uh
that's uh projected to happen by 2030 uh
it's an issue that needs to be addressed
whether it's at the state Regional or
national level and the fact that there's
currently no easy regulation of these
costs is a true difficulty and uh has
the potential to be costly for New
Hampshire rap
bears and then I wanted to wrap up my
part of the discussion on uh winter
reliability issues
um you know obviously winter is the time
where we want to main maintain our
reliability right when the power goes
out and there's no way to heat your home
it it you can uh risk
uh significant health and economic
outcomes for the people in New Hampshire
uh winter reliability issues are
distinct from from those in the summer
in the summer you're more likely to see
issues that are shorter in duration and
are related to an acute issue like a
generator uh going offline or or an
issue with transmission infrastructure
or even the forecasted load uh in Winter
the issues are different and that's
where we see our gas pipeline
constraints really come into effect um
gas capacity gets eaten up by uh you
know home heating load and that
consequently limits the availability of
natural gas for electric generation and
so that's when you start to see
significant price hikes and our system
moves over to uh rely on oil for
electric generation now that's both
expensive and and oil is also a stored
fuel so if you have significant periods
of time where you're uh relying on oil
using up that stored fuel uh you you
risk situations where if resupply is is
difficult or impossible and and uh you
know we're running short on capacity we
will see short uh shortfalls in capacity
and that's both expensive and likely to
lead to longer term sustained uh
problems uh which which could be weeks
long um now our current resource mix
looks ready to meet the needs through
2032 it depends really on on which
projections you're looking at but the
region uh does need to find long-term
solutions that balance supply and demand
and encourage investment that improve uh
winter performance so uh Mr chairman you
did ask us to talk about the renewable
portfolio standards so I'm going to
invite our uh policy and programs
director Josh Elliott to come up and uh
discuss the RPS and then we can get to
questions
well I was thinking that in order to
avoid the problem of musical chairs
maybe we should uh ask a few questions
of you gentlemen first before we move to
the RPS discussion would that be
agreeable to you and does the committee
think that's a good idea
that that's fine with us I think we
reserve the right to to call and pinch
hitters if we're diving deep into a
specific topic where we have somebody
who might be able to provide you the the
best answer understood just trying to
keep U chair exchanges to a minimum uh
questions for these two gentlemen
representative Kaplan has
one thank you Mr chair and uh thank you
gentlemen uh for coming to give us your
report this morning uh you mentioned
that New Hampshire has a goal oriented
approach u in difference with our
neighboring states so I wanted to hear
more about your the you know New
Hampshire's goal oriented approach and
how that relates to uh the scenario that
you envision in order to meet our
long-term demand as opposed to the the
clean energy transition that is outlined
in the iso report sure that's a great
question and I think it really ties into
a technology neutral approach or you
know what some folks will will call an
all of the above uh energy approach and
and what we argued and what the state
energy strategy States is that when
you're looking at an energy policy
especially when it relates to a resource
uh or what the resource mix should be
you shouldn't look at at trying to
promote a resource for the sake of
promoting that resource we should
identify the goals whe whether they're
uh price whether they're reliability
whether they're uh you know clean energy
related and build that structure so that
what we're looking to achieve is that
outcome rather than saying we want to
promote we want more natural gas we want
more solar we want nuclear whatever it
is and and to identify what do we want
our our results to be and then build a
system where uh you know a market uh
where where competition can help to find
the most efficient resource at meeting
those needs uh you know when we pick
winners and
losers I think it's fair to say more
often than not government does not find
the optimal solution and so by building
a structure where you are focused on the
goal you want to achieve provided that
the goal is not we want this resource
for its own sake um or we're not going
to uh disregard a resource simply by
virtue of being that resource uh you're
going to find more optimal more
efficient outcomes so it doesn't say
don't do clean energy goals don't try to
find a reliable resource it means it
means identify what you want and then
let let the market deliver what's
best any additional questions uh
representative
Summers thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question I actually
have a a two-part question if I can to
jam it in the first one is probably
going to be a short a very quick answer
but uh the first one being that uh we
know about uh last term term before we
brought up a lading prices we know that
the Pu has had an open docket about
looking into laddering electrical rates
from the supply side and where we know
New Hampshire co-op uh has a lading is
docket still remain open with the Pu and
does the department of energy have
standing in this rate and lading that's
the first part sorry about that and the
second one I have for you is while you
represent while you state that the New
Hampshire has 10% of the load and Mystic
um with Mystic closing in Massachusetts
how much of the what percentage of the
power does New Hampshire itself generate
of the iso New England
states those are great questions uh I
will start with the first one so the Pu
does have a uh well in the pu's
proceedings related to the procurement
of default service electricity so that's
that you know last resort electricity uh
they have been
undertaking um a a a more market-based
approach towards procuring that
electricity so for a long time New
Hampshire's policy has been for the
utilities who who don't make a profit
under Supply at all
um they they built a framework uh for uh
self or excuse me for for uh energy
Supply that involves competitive bidding
from competitive uh electricity
suppliers
um after looking at data that suggests
that there's significant risk premiums
associated with those bids and that
there there might be opportunities to
save right payers money by uh exposing
them to to directly to the market
um they they've uh endeavored
to add an increasing amount of that
supply of market-based supply to the mix
uh we're still relatively early in that
process but those tranches of
electricity that have been procured um
that have that market exposure have seen
we've seen significantly lower rates uh
associated with that obviously there's a
lot that that that goes into um you know
uh moving more towards utility
self-supply in relationship to you know
what the utilities have to have on hand
to be able to meet whatever needs that
come in uh risks for uh Major Market
changes but I I would say we are
encouraged by the pricing that we've
seen there which has seen substantial
savings over what um has has
historically been been seen for uh
competitive Supply bits um so you know I
think lading is is is an approach that
really the the conversation around
lading which involves uh layering those
procurements over um from from several
periods of the year and and blending
that together to bring in more price
stability that conversation really
started to get uh going and gain a lot
more traction when we saw electricity
prices spike in 2022 mostly in relation
to the Russian invasion of Ukraine um
you know what we saw through that
process New Hampshire did not do lading
right and and our neighbors did we saw
that New Hampshire saw price spikes
early uh we also saw price reductions
much much faster than our our neighbors
did and when you look at the overall
costs New Hampshire Rays paid
significantly less than than our
neighbors who did uh you know pursue
lading um you know if you look at
something I had this data at one point
I'm sorry I don't really know it off the
top of my head but it was it was at
three years looking back and if you
looked at um what we what our default
service right payers were paying for
default service it was something like we
paid higher uh than the rest of the
region in like five of the 36 months and
in the rest we we saw savings so I right
now I think the lattering conversation
has been um put on hold a little bit as
we've seen more sustain you know that
return to normal following the invasion
um you know obviously it's a it's a
topic of conversation and that if that's
where folks want to go you know that's
going to be something we all have to
look at uh the conversation really has
moved more towards looking at that
market-based uh utility
self-supply um when it comes to you know
uh how we want to change our default
service procurement and I'm sorry I I
just talked myself out of remembering
what your second question was that sorry
about that um and second part was the uh
with the closing of Mystic down in
Massachusetts while you said stated that
New Hampshire provides it it has 10
takes 10% of the load of electrical rate
what percentage of uh generation is
created in the state of New
Hampshire I believe it's somewhere
between 15 and and 20% um but I'll look
to
177% thank
you okay additional questions
representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you both for coming
here um when when Deputy Commissioner
Elms spoke of the asset condition
problem uh I I naively would think that
that this is actually a good thing
because uh maintaining the existing
lines is important for reliability yet I
got this undertone from you that there's
there's an issue here and I'd like to
hear more about that please sure and and
I don't Dan if you want to jump in feel
free to to come up here um you know
maintaining reliability as I said that's
priority number one and maintaining
those lines is is very important and I
know a lot of that conversation has been
in the context of the North Country I'll
tell you know I wouldn't call myself a
North Country guy but a White Mountains
guy certainly and and you know we saw
eversource heading up to Sugar Hill um
to to deal with some issues on this line
uh recently I'll you know that's where
my my father lives and you know spent a
lot of time there so I am certainly not
uh unsympathetic to the needs of of of
our folks to the north um the question
is whether or not the spending that
we're doing to maintain that reliability
is is all focused on on maintaining that
right we want to maintain reliability
but the question is you know are we are
we spending the right dollars and are we
spending too much on on what's needed
there um I I don't want to tell you that
the answer is necessarily yes or no I'd
say we have some real concerns about uh
what those numbers are and it's been
difficult to find out what we we um you
know need need to know on on a a variety
of projects that are not limited to New
Hampshire so this is this is not uh a
specific project uh issue um I think
we've had a lot of attention related to
to one that's that's in New Hampshire
but uh it's a concern we have going into
the next 5 10 years because we've really
seen that a lot of the reliability
spending of the of the first half of of
or or the last decade was focused on
building out that infrastructure and now
basically we've we've built what we are
going to build and and so when we're
seeing the increasing spending happening
on maintaining those lines we think it's
important that we have regulatory
oversight that's the whole that's the
whole thing we're doing here uh building
out that infrastructure has significant
stakeholder input on the regional level
it has significant uh regulatory
oversight on that Regional level but
this class of maintaining at you know
these asset condition projects uh does
fall into this sweet spot where there
really is not uh a level of oversight
that that we would feel comfortable
having uh when it comes to utility
regulation uh Dan I don't know if you
want to add to that Dan failen I sorry I
keep going back to is our regional
policy director and he's a uh he's our
uh co- Nesco manager alongside
commissioner sha coin Nesco being the
New England states committee on
electricity and that's the group of the
states uh coming together to have these
negotiations so uh hope that answered
your question representative Wendy
Thomas thank you Mr chair um this is in
regard to slide 15 which is winter
reliability um we know that that our
Winters are getting warmer have you
factored in temperature change um
through
2032 uh for your projections and if so
what resources did you use sure and and
uh Dan feel free to come up if you know
more about this but this is um you know
a lot of the analysis that's that's out
there is from you know ISO New England
and other resources like that so a lot
of that uh analysis um was not done by
Doe specifically I I do think that it uh
accounts for a variety of weather
projections and climate projections um
yeah thank you thanks for the question
so uh the the data reference there was
an ISO study that looked out to 2032 it
used the most extreme winter scenarios
uh I believe that it was the winter of
62 uh that was the the worst winter that
they found over looking out over the
recent history um and and it found
adequate
uh adequate resources uh as far as we
can tell for her now with the current
resource mix and the current anticipated
retirements and new resources um
obviously if things don't go according
to schedule over the next five years
then uh the the situation gets different
but right now it it looks in good shape
thank you um representative follow Mr
chair oh you need a followup okay yes
please um Dan don't go anywhere um so
conversely we know that our summers are
getting hotter and we're using a lot of
energy in the Summers so is there any
concern about summer reliability so
there is it's uh currently we are a
summer peaking system the anticipation
is that we will move to a winter peaking
system which means the the winter issues
will be uh will require more Supply in
the winter than during the summer um and
Chris spoke about sort of the
differences between the summer and the
winter they're kind of different problem
they're they're a weekl long winter cold
snap but that we're in the middle of
right now the problem is having enough
fuel for the entire period as opposed to
meaning that
acute Peak period in the summer um
they're just different kinds of problems
and they require different kinds of
Solutions Representative Doug
Thomas thank you Mr chair um we all know
that that we have some short-term
challenges coming up particularly in
terms of um pricing in the power grid
and everything but on a longer term
basis and more to the fact that you know
people are now beginning to talk about
smallscale nuclear particularly ISO uh
ISO New England is talking about it um
EU has talked about it uh a lot of the
states are beginning to you know look
into it um we see a real uh potential
here for New Hampshire to take advantage
of the of this new technology what is
your department doing to both facil
facilitate uh and interest investors
perhaps into coming into the state and
also in terms of getting the word out
that this really is a good thing in the
not too distant future but still a few
years down line we have to attack the
cost issue of it and also the perception
as well so what's the what's the O's uh
um status of of this up you know this
indication you know yeah it's a it's a
great question and it's one that um in
the I I mentioned before Oh the uh is
New England epet report they actually do
talk a little bit about um Alternatives
that can help reduce uh some of the
buildout that would be necessary to meet
clean energy goals and one of the the uh
scenarios that they looked at was the
addition of um you know more small
modular nuclear reactors and advanced
nuclear reactors uh to help offset that
and what they found is that uh the
buildout uh if that buildout included a
significant portion of the load um being
represented by nuclear power that it
would significantly reduce the
inefficiency that we talked about um
because it's obviously a scalable uh
clean energy resource um you know there
are challenges associated with nuclear
power specifically just at the
development of the technology where it
is today uh and and and today's costs um
which are High um you know as to what
doe is doing uh the legislature uh last
year in their wisdom uh added to our our
responsibilities within our office of
offshore wind industry development
responsibilities for energy Innovation
um and that uh included a significant um
review that the department is is and
will be undertaking of you know what
are what are our states uh you know you
know hurdles obstacles roadblocks to uh
the development of nuclear power uh
we're one of a few states that in New
England that does not have a ban on
nuclear power coming in uh new nuclear
power coming in um so as part of that
bill you did also give us the
opportunity to uh hire staff to be a uh
a essentially a nuclear coordinator um
somebody will know the the right title
there uh but and that position is posted
uh on our on our jobs portal so we or if
it's not now it it will be reposted uh
you know
obviously attracting nuclear experts to
state government service is a difficulty
because if you're an expert on nuclear
power you can make a lot of money in the
private sector uh but we are doing what
we can to facilitate um you know uh a
regulatory structure that allows
resources you know to come
in representative Bernardi has a
question thank you Mr chair uh looking
at your ISO New England epet report
there how realistic do you believe those
projected build outs of wind and solar
are what are the costs anticipated for
uh New Hampshire citizens in their rates
what kind of increase would you see and
uh assuming that this does not
materialize um what kind of backup is
needed for truly reliable
power sure it's a good question and um
Dan can come tap me on the shoulder I
don't believe the epet report itself
looked at the specific cost projection
associated with this buildout I think
there was a recent report from the jiah
Bartlet Center that that looked at a I
think a more significant buildout than
what was projected under epet and I
think that projection was something like
doubling the cost of
electricity uh you know for folks um in
terms of the realistic you know whether
or not it's realistic um you know we've
seen real difficulties in sighting
infrastructure in in New Hampshire and
and I think there's a lot of
uh there's obviously a lot of
problems trying to get get things done
just from a sighting perspective before
you even start to think about costs now
when we're looking at costs things like
offshore wind um have been a resource
that's looked at as a as a scalable
clean resource um that that might be
necessary to actually maintain
reliability needs uh if you're going to
have um uh you know meet the clean
energy goals offshore wind's very
expensive the last solicitation I saw
and I might be behind the times here but
it was about $150 megawatt hour uh in
New York
and that's you know what four or five
times as expensive as the market market
price U maybe maybe yeah three or four
um we have this solicitation um
Massachusetts Connecticut Rhode Island
wanted to do a joint procurement of
offshore wind we saw Connecticut did not
join what those results were I don't
know if we've seen the results of that
solicitation
Dan okay so we Haven we haven't seen
what the actual cost projections are uh
yet but um
we know that Connecticut said this was
too too rich for our blood and they
backed out of it so uh there
are real kind of concerns associated
with you know this epet report does also
assume that we're going to build out
some of the offshore wind that's been
planned we've seen real difficulties and
delays in building out that offshore
wind so the more and more that happens
the more and more those reliability
projections become less Rosy and they're
already not that great to begin with and
then uh you know the costs are only
going to go up uh
so I don't know if that answers your
question but uh it's it's not it's not a
um it's not a problem that that won't
have uh complexities a lot of hard work
and uh maybe some hopes and prayers
associated with
them representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking my question and thank you for
being here this morning with us again um
yeah my question also is around uh the
costs of these future projections that
you're talking about um I'm wondering
whether doe is um engaged at all in
trying to determine sort of least cost
outcomes you because if
if the way I look at New Hampshire
energy policy is that we want to be
setting a
trajectory and when I first started
paying attention to the energy policy in
the state that was exactly what the
10-year strategy report did it set a
trajectory it talked based on um
individual sectors of the energy economy
as to what the plans were for both
lowering emissions and addressing the
climate concerns the pollution concerns
and also managing for the lowest cost
but one of the things I think you're
alluding to with the conversation that
just went by is that as we're going on
the answers the solutions to our
problems whether it's reliability you
know getting the energy into the state
the costs of those are going up and the
state of New Hampshire can be proud that
we're not in the same boat as all the
folks around us but we also don't have a
plan in terms of the trajectory and I'm
concerned that without a plan for how
we're going to get there that we can
actually point to and work on that we
will end up paying the most not the
least so that I'll just leave it there
no and I appreciate that and you know
we've had some conversations
representative on on this topic over the
years I think you know you alluded to
you know making sure we can meet those
climate goals and and lower emissions
you know if you folks are interested in
passing that bill and and the governor
signs it into law we're happy to you
know include that in terms of in our
decision-making the legislature has
repeatedly over the years rejected uh
decarbonization goals as a goal and have
strengthened our responsibility to argue
against the cost shifting of policies so
you know as as an executive branch
agency we're trying to implement the law
as the legislature has passed it and and
what the legislature has done is say no
we want to focus uh not on
decarbonization but on cost and
affordability and we want you to argue
against Shifting the cost of those
policies you know to New Hampshire um
you know looking forward I it is a
difficult problem right and we
are well I don't want to say it's
inextricable because you know we are
tied to our neighbors for now and you
know I know that there's conversation
and I know that there's legislation
pending that would look at what is New
Hampshire's proper role in The Grid in
ISO New England do we want to look at
Alternatives do we want to look at
alternative regulatory structures that
may might not involve us leaving but
saying how can we further uh insulate
ourselves you know in accordance with
our our you know uh statutory mandate to
uh protect against cost shifting you
know you look at a state like Vermont
that's not vertically integrated and
they don't have a significant share of
their load tied up in the iso New
England markets maybe that's something
that that New Hampshire is going to look
at I think um should the should the
legislature move forward with a bill
having us look into that um you know
that we're going to explore every Avenue
to to do precisely what what sounds like
you're asking for us to do because uh
the the regional context is it's it's a
difficult one right you know if we're
only 10% of the load we we don't have um
the ability to just say this is what New
Hampshire wants
uh get it done we do a pretty good job
you know and and we've done uh we've
been pretty successful in working with
our neighbors to um tailor policies to
to uh you know kind of both account for
our neighbors needs while while looking
out for New Hampshire's interest I you
know um at some point it's a topic he
could go on for several hours about but
if you want to talk more about um uh
phase two of I New England's uh
transmission planning that's something
where we worked with our neighbors to
say you know what are your needs what is
that Baseline sort of resource need that
we can all agree on and and say okay New
Hampshire we agree to pay for those
things that are you know beneficial to
us under our formula anything over the
top of that if if it doesn't work out
right those are going to be costs that
other states have to go on I'm and I'm
going way out over my skis because you
know uh he's he's the guy negotiating
those types of things but there really
is a lot of work that we we do um you
know and we have a we have a good
relationship with our neighbors again
sometimes we just know we can't agree
with them but uh we do we don't see
ourselves as being free of the the the
regional context uh we have to make
do okay representative uh representative
SW Swanson has a question and then I
think we after that we need to move on
to the
RPS I just to springboard on uh the plan
issue that was mentioned and I was going
to describe more about my investment in
solar panels and whole house and the
fact that uh I got my first
net uh charge from eversource this past
month for the past eight months I have
been providing through the benefit of
net metering back into the Grid
electricity and there's a long ways to
go but I believe in investing in the
future and it can be
expensive uh it'll probably take a long
time hopefully I'll live long enough to
see a return on investment but
investment is important and I recognize
that there is legislation in
place uh from the past based upon
previous concerns and certainly
expensive is a term I've heard several
times and we don't want to make things
too expensive but sometimes it is
worthwhile investing because what I'm
missing from these graphs is well what
is the stability
of and it sounds like a plan the basic
plan is to continue relying heavily on
fossil
fuels uh oil gas whatever and uh uh it's
not clear for me that there's 100%
transmission to Renewables in this but I
haven't seen a cost analys analysis or a
guarantee of the Avail availability of
fossil fuels over the next 25 years so
uh but that not not
withstanding uh it's noted here that uh
we'll need 18 times the current combined
capacity within the next 25 years now I
jumped on solar with my house because I
felt the technology was ready and we
have new technologies becoming available
all the time and I'm not going to you
know I just want to move off of that
dependence what my question is is this
this was a 25e
goal and uh what I'm
the feeling I'm getting is let's stick
with the the the mix we currently have
and just try to make sure every megawatt
or kilowatt or watt is as cheap as
possible right now based upon current
capacity and capability and
Technology I'm not hearing much about
investment or rather I hear resistance
to investment in the future and the uh I
have a two-part question is your plan
for the next 25 years recommend ing a
continued mix of dependence on fossil
fuels at the current
percentage through that 25 years or is
there a longer term plan to or any plan
to move into Renewables and off of
dependent from fossil fuels which will
probably get more expensive as they
become more scarce because we all know
that fossil fuels are a finite resource
thank you sure thank you for the
question um yeah so so there is no
current plan to transition us entirely
off fossil fuels and that's based on us
um you know helping to implement the
statutory obligations that the
legislature has passed if the
legislature wants us to pursue a
strategy that involves a 100% transition
away from fossil fuels um they're
perfectly at Liberty to do so and if the
bill passed and was signed into law we
would be uh happy to and statutory
obligated to uh Implement that uh it's
not currently the case um you know when
it comes to uh trying to pick the right
percentage of our resource mix falling
to fossil fuels that's also something
we're not doing what we're trying to do
is say we want to we want to maintain
our reliability we want to prioritize
low cost and we want to build a system
and and you know uh ISO New England uh
they manage the wholesale markets uh
where a lot of the power you know uh for
New England is procured and and that is
designed that market is designed not to
necessarily deliver uh clean energy it's
designed to deliver reliable lowcost
electricity um so yeah I wouldn't say
that we have a goal of fossil fuels at
this percentage Renewables you know at
this percentage outside of the renewable
portfolio standard which we're going to
hear uh about uh very soon um you know
our our goal has been to find the most
efficient resources to meet our needs um
you know when the conversation about net
metering just to briefly talk about that
um you know our goal is not to you know
through net metering net metering is not
designed to be subsidy it's designed to
be fair compensation for um you know
what's the the power that's being put
onto the grid uh for the power that's
avoided um so you know in an Ideal World
right the net metering rate is not a um
a subsidy rate it's a it's a it's fair
compensation so um you know our we don't
have a state goal of delivering
X number of gws of solar power uh on any
particular time frame it's develop the
fair rate that compensates uh for the
benefits that that whatever the
distributed generation resource uh is
that you're net metering um that's
that's what the goal is well I want to
thank you Mr commissioner and Mr Deputy
Commissioner for this uh excellent
overview of the Department's roles and
responsibilities in the executive branch
and and I'd like now for uh you to
transition to a examination of the
renewable portfolio standard happy to do
so and I'm gonna stay up here we're
going to invite uh director Josh Elliott
to to talk about the
RPS welcome Mr Elliot good to see you
again morning Mr chairman uh members of
the committee good to see you as well um
good to meet the new members as well uh
for the record Josh Elliott I serve as
the Director of the division of policy
and programs uh with the New Hampshire
Department of energy um representative
rolds who I realize is on the way out
the door I was born and raised in
Westfield massachusett so right next
door to a
Springfield glad I caught you before you
walked out anyway um so I am talking
today uh at the request of the uh chair
to do a little bit of a deeper dive into
the renewable portfolio standard um so
as I walk through these just a uh one
caveat uh to talk about some exceptions
uh up front this is a broad brush stroke
um they're always going to be little
nuances little exceptions to certain
things that I say I did not dive into
all the minutia of the details but just
wanted to give sort of a broad picture
of what this looks like accurately but
there might be little things here and
there like oh well except for etc etc
and I didn't want to clog up my slides
with all those
exceptions so this is the renewable
portfolio standard or the RPS is set in
statute and it's in RSA 363 F uh where
providers of electricity are required to
obtain and then retire a certain number
of uh renewable energy certificates or
Recs uh to cover their sales for the
prior year now that's a very loaded
sentence so I'm going to sort of break
that out a lot a little bit so providers
of electricity who are these people
these are any entities that sell
electricity uh in the state of New
Hampshire so that includes the regulated
utilities that includes competitive
suppliers it includes um other
aggregation plans such as Community
power um Freedom Logistics there's a
couple of them that are operating uh in
that space
so they are required to cover a certain
percentage and we're going to get to
those percentages and how they do that
of their sales with what are called
renewable energy certificates or wrecks
so what the heck is a wreck so a wreck
is is a representation of the renewable
attributes of
electricity so um I know the Deputy
Commissioner uses uses this analogy
frequently and I think it's a good one
um imagine if you will uh pool in the
backyard you have a cup of water you
dump the cup of water into the pool then
you say well I want my cup of water back
right you can't go down to the molecular
level and grab every single last water
molecule that you dropped into that pool
right you can get a cup of water you can
make sure it's exactly the same amount
but you can't get your cup of water back
uh and the same thing works with
electricity right just based on pure
physics you cannot track the individual
you know electrons wiggling back and
forth and the electrical grid is to
where it's being generated versus where
it's being consumed right it follows the
laws of physics wherever there is the
uh um demand for that electricity the
electricity will flow in that direction
with a couple of exceptions obviously
there's lots of switching around of the
things um in terms of the actual
infrastructure so the wreck is designed
to solve that question right because if
you are right next to a say a wind
turbine or a solar array right just
based on where the lines are drawn or
the where the lines um meet your uh
meter all of that electricity would
necessarily go right to you but right
you're not necessarily the one who can
claim oh I have 100% r energy just
because I happen to live next door to
one of these
facilities so the r is designed to sort
of divide the actual generation from
electricity to from the actual renewable
attributes which is where you're able to
say okay I can claim that I am 100%
renewable I can claim you know what all
you know those renewable attributes
whereas the actual electricity generated
by those facilities you don't you the
it's just consumed just based on where
uh the interconnection points are so one
wreck uh is equal to one megawatt hour
of electricity production so New
Hampshire has four types of uh four
classes or four and a half really on is
a subset uh within the renewable
portfolio standard um so you can see
them on your screen there I'm not going
to read each of them but essentially
it's class one or are new
technologies uh class one thermal which
is a subset of class one um is for the
useful thermal energy so heat
essentially um that is created by one of
these uh resources class class two is
solar class three is existing biomass uh
as well as methane and then class four
is existing small scale hydros um
there's always going to be a number of
caveats if you look in the statues
there's a whole bunch of caveats that
that spell out each of those um each of
those pieces um but essentially those
are sort of the broad categories where
those um uh within the RPS of what the
electricity suppliers need to be able to
purchase recks from each of those
individual classes so for example if I
am a solar array so that's a bad example
I'm going to use small scale Hydro so my
small scale Hydro um that had an
inservice date before the date set in
statute I am only generating class 4
recks for every megawatt hour production
that I sent out to the grid so there's a
one to one comparison there but it's
only class one I'm not generate I'm
sorry class four I'm not generating
class three I'm not generating class two
not generating class one it's just class
four
Rex so the way that the uh these re and
I'm going to go into more detail about
that
a good description of how um re actually
function so re themselves um actually I
shouldn't say rather generating they're
minted um so basically there's like a
little certificate that comes with each
of them um they're bought and sold in an
open market So within New England all of
these reck trade uh and are offered for
sale and then sold and then retired
essentially means they're used
essentially um on a regional level so
that means you know if there is a um uh
we'll use the hydroelectric facility
hydroelectric facility fac is creating
class 4 re here in New Hampshire and
rting them um they in theory could be
bought by a utility in Connecticut and
then retired there to meet one of their
compliance requirements um the classes
all are inter uh are all mixed up so a
class one in New Hampshire might be a
class three in Vermont might be a class
four in Connecticut um so there's
there's a great chart in our annual
report that actually overlays each of
these so these suppliers of electricity
have to go out into this open market and
buy a certain number of wrecks to meet
the individual
classes um excuse me to uh to meet the
requirements set in the statutes so what
happens if they can't find them right
what if there's the the there's no none
of them are available out there or if
they're at a high enough price um they
are requireed they are allowed to under
the statute make what's called an
alternative compliance payment or an ACP
so this is a rate that's set in statute
that functions as a price cap so and uh
prevents the situation where um you know
there might be so much demand for
particular type of wreck that the price
just Spirals and Spirals and spirals
Because the bidding just keeps driving
it higher and higher so the alternative
compliance payment basically some
functions as a cap where the price may
go up and up and up and up then all the
way to the cap those um individual uh
electricity suppliers can just say okay
if I were to look in the open market uh
the trading price I'm making up numbers
here for this wreck is $60 but the ACP
is set at 55 I'm going to pay the $55
rather than buy this for
60 so the way that those the ACP um uh
cap is set in statute and then it's
indexed for inflation um so it will um
as you can see on the slide there uh
classes three and four by um CPI with uh
classes one and two by half of
CPI so what exactly are we talking about
in terms of the actual settlement of
this so for 20 compliance year 2025
which is starting uh started just a few
days ago January 1 um there's a
requirement that
25.2% of all electricity consumed within
the state of New Hampshire must be come
come from what are considered renewable
resources and the legislature has
defined renewable resources within each
of those classes so for example this is
a a perfect way of walking through and I
use try to use numbers that you get nice
round number so pretend I am an
electricity supplier right and I've sold
100 excuse me a th000 megawatt hours of
electricity that's tiny for for supplier
but works for the um example here so if
I've sold 1,000 megawatt hour of
electricity here in New Hampshire I am
required based on the statute and based
on the percentages there to obtain and
retire 252 wrecks in order to meet that
25.2% but it's not just any wreck I need
to get a certain number of the right
kinds of wrecks so for class one I need
to make sure that I have 128 non-thermal
or just electric wrecks and 22 thermal
wrecks to meet my class one obligation
for class two I'd need to obtain 70
wrecks in order to meet that obligation
for class three I'd need to to obtain
and retire 800 class 3 recks to meet
that requirement and finally for class 4
I need to obtain and then retire 150
class 4
recks so all of that uh is done uh
within a within a compliance year uh the
compliance year runs from January 1st to
December 31st of each uh calendar year
uh and then there's a compliance period
between uh July 1st and July 15th of
every year uh where the utilities the uh
electricity suppliers then report to the
Department of their sales and then
evidence that they have purchased and
then retired the appropriate number of
Recs or um at that point they will then
make the alternative compliance payment
so they'll essentially um pay that uh
pay that
in uh so any of those funds that are
received in um by the department um are
deposited into what's referred to as the
renewable energy fund um and then those
uh funds are used by the department to
fund renewable Technologies so uh the re
funds as you can see on the screen there
um three rebate programs for commercial
industrial solar projects commercial
industrial wood pellet projects as well
as residential wood pellet projects
there's three competitive Grant programs
uh a commercial industrial um
competitive program that's just open uh
a low moderate income solar program uh
as well as a municipal solar program so
that Municipal solar program um for
those of you who were here last year may
recall Senate Bill 303 um which directed
the department to set up a specific
Municipal program we are uh will
hopefully have a uh straw proposal um
out for stakeholder comment in the next
couple of weeks here and of course
obviously there are costs um born by the
department um for both uh on the RPS uh
compliance side as well as um uh
maintaining uh the the appropriate
Administration over these programs um so
there's some there's a portion that
comes out for administrative fees um and
then any related issues is directed in
the
statute so this last slide um this is
just to give you a sense of what the
costs are for the renewable portfolio
standard in a given year um so this is
back uh back to 2008 with the most
recently completed um compliance year
being 2023 on the right hand side of
your slide there um the green indicated
uh is the cost for the electric supplies
of electricity to purchase and then
retire those wrecks uh whereas the blue
are the alternative compliance payments
so those are the payments where they
could either could not find or
administratively difficult to find uh or
difficult to um find and retire those
recks for those of the payments um that
are made into the state so you can see
um the renewable portfolio standard had
a had an escalator built in um that has
has basically it's gone up to 2025 and
then we've we've reached the last step
so you can see those costs have sort of
escalated uh over the recent years with
the notable exception of last year but
this is a good illustration of why um
those renewable energy certificates that
are traded uh that there's a regional
New England wide market for those which
which dictates price so you can see is
the U price in any given year um for
those uh to settle those wrecks uh
varies from year to year so with that
I'm happy to take a pause there realize
there's a lot of information a lot of
acronyms all thrown in there so thank
you I remember in 2015 when I was a
freshman and I started attending or I
attended the orientation of st& and
there were presentations like yours for
two days in a row I remember thinking I
was drinking from a fire hose and uh so
you've given us a great example of that
here today I have two questions for you
one is a specific question about uh Rex
and the other is a kind of a more
general question the the specific
question is do you know how many Rex
purchased in New Hampshire are sold
elsewhere I don't know that number off
the top of my head but I can uh I can
check with staff and figure out that
would vary from year to year um because
it would just go of the the price dick
and to that point so a New Hampshire
class one wreck might have uh attributes
that qualify them for uh another New
England State's RPS under a different
class so um you know these are all
happening in a market it can be you know
difficult to track oh where did this one
specific wreck you know end up uh
because that class one wreck in New
Hampshire might be a class whatever in
Connecticut okay see what you can do to
come up with a a general number if you
can my more my broader question is about
the whole program itself as you know the
program plateaus in
2025 when it was originally passed back
in
2007 it 2025 seemed like a long way
away and I suppose back then it was but
we're there now
so this would appear to be the correct
time to try to evaluate the success or
failure of this
program so the question for you is does
the department have any metrics or
any uh
methodology for determining has the
RPS succeeded in achieving its
goals or not and if it has not succeeded
in achieving its goals what reforms
would need to be made to it so that it
could achieve its
goals thank you that's a great question
and so uh you know there is going to be
a more comprehensive review I think at
statutory um not rules uh of the RPS
that that happens this year and that's
something that the department will be
undertaking you know when you look at
and and this kind of goes back to
representative kaplan's question from
earlier you know about being goals
oriented and what does that mean you
know looking back to the RPS and what
sort of the enabling statute uh asks for
right you know in in terms of promoting
clean energy fuel diversity um and those
things are you know New Hampshire
Economic Development whatever it might
be um those are important goals they're
ones that are also oftentimes hard to
you know people can come up with numbers
but you know you have to say well what
is this dollar really incenting
um I will say and I have to be a little
you know not careful but uh we wrote a
10-year State energy strategy under the
previous administration obviously we've
had a a change in executive bran
leadership so uh something I didn't note
before but I do want to talk about is we
are going to be undertaking another
revision of the state energy strategy
this year um so we will um Mr chairman
ask to come back and uh present and and
take questions from the committee as
we're statutorily obligated to do um so
that's that's something comes in there
but so with that caveat uh under the
current strategy we do suggest what some
of those possible reforms could look
like uh when it comes to the renewable
portfolio standard um as we as we talked
about uh we do like market-based
approaches and competitive approaches so
what can we do to further facilitate um
the most efficient selection of
resources that meet those goals that we
have that the RPS has um we've we've
asked the question um and I know it's
come up in the past
why not a resource like nuclear why not
a resource like larger scale Hydro that
might be able to achieve or help us
achieve some of those um clean energy um
you know considerations some of those uh
uh energy diversity considerations and
and frankly might have uh you know good
Economic Development opportunities in
New Hampshire uh why do we have so many
classes and why do we not uh encourage
further competition not not between say
a fossil fuel resource and a renewable
resource but but within those renewable
energy resources why why not say you
know let's find one that helps us meet
or or find whichever ones help us meet
that those goals in the most uh cost
effective way possible um you know the
current situation I I would Hazard to
guess does probably leave some meat on
the bone when it comes to um you know uh
providing uh Financial incentives to
resources that might be beyond what is
necessary to actually incent that
resource uh but because there are um
these these very strict uh classes um we
we we might not be seeing the most
efficient selection of those of those
resources so um you know we are
undertaking a we're going to be
undertaking a review uh and that's part
of what came in with the uh maturity of
of the RPS in
2025 okay additional questions
representative Doug Thomas
thank you micher uh actually um very
similar question to what the chairman
asked but I was going to ask it in more
simplistic
terms and basically for the benefit of
our newest members here the um the
briefing you gave excellent briefing but
could you
explain why or what was the original
purpose of the RPS program um and to
that question
what happens when we meet that purpose
or is this a particular purpose that has
no end so can you address those concerns
sure and and I'll just give you I was in
high school when when this came into
effect so I don't I wasn't there for the
legislative uh you know history there I
you know there are legislative findings
that talk about the value of um you know
uh renewable resources and and uh you
know fuel diversity economic development
in New Hampshire so I think that those
are uh laid out in in the statute
um yeah uh so you
know when it comes to achieve achieving
those right you know uh I think we would
all agree we want to make sure we meet
our goals uh as cost effectively as
possible right uh so that's that's
really something that people uh need to
do and I'm sorry I forgot the if I left
out part of your
question well uh I was trying to get you
to talk about what happens when we get
there is this is this a program that has
an endpoint or is a program with no end
because people just wanted to keep
continuing sure yeah and and yeah
apologies for losing it there yeah no uh
it doesn't have an end point right now
uh under statute it plateaus at this
25.2% level um again that 25.2 does have
some fluctuation in it and Josh didn't
get into it I don't think but you know
the department does have the ability to
adjust just classes three and four based
on sort of what the availability might
be um you know because there are
circumstances where you know for
instance if they're and we've done this
the past three or four years uh where
there just weren't going to be enough uh
wrecks available for class three if it
represents 8% of our generation at a
high ACP it was just going to be
needlessly expensive for rate payers so
we've we had the legislative authority
to uh bring that down in previous last
two years I think it was we've brought
it down to 0.5% % from the eight um and
we're undergoing a proceeding to look at
that
currently okay representative McGee did
you have your hand
up I did it's easier to ask who doesn't
have their hand up from the looks of it
okay so um I I had a couple of thoughts
um so we're talking about class three
and that's an interesting place to start
when we talk about RPS conception
or whether it's good whether it's bad
whether it's meeting its goals uh
whatever those are um for me it would be
important to bring it back to who are
using these wrecks who are benefiting
from these wrecks who are
operating uh their generation concerns
based on you know the the Rex being a
part of the economic model that allows
them to operate in the state um class 3
Rex went down I was here when we passed
the biomass Bill HP 183 it's burned in
my head um that affected many biomass uh
businesses in the state of New Hampshire
who were indigenous
businesses and we didn't spend a lot of
we we heard from them but we didn't
spend a lot of time
discussing the impacts of those you know
new hampshire-based
uh generation facilities that also were
helping the timber industry you know
they had a lot of connections to other
um economic interests in the state of
New Hampshire um and so I guess my
question is we seem to be talking about
this as something out there that are
just three letters that we can just do
something but we're not talking about it
in terms of what does the RPS mean to
indigenous Industries and businesses in
the state of New
Hampshire um so that we can understand
the impact of any decision that we make
you're not you're not really giving us
enough information
about uh my understanding is the RPS was
set up in order to help us reach a goal
by 2025 of 25% of our energy generation
being done with Renewables or with
cleaner energy sources right so we set
that as a goal we may be fairly close to
that with what's going on behind the
meter I don't know you guys haven't told
us that but rather than just throwing it
up in the air without even having
discussed the actual impacts on maybe
some of the people in this room and also
um you know some of the businesses that
are genuinely trying to create Supply
diversity in the state can you just talk
about that a little bit because Supply
diversity actually it doesn't just help
us with reliability it helps us keep
dollars in the state our energy dollars
in the state and it um it makes us more
secure it it it helps lower some of the
risk of us having to get everything from
out of state so I think it's worth
talking about and that's what I would
like to understand is what what does
this chart represent in terms of
businesses I know I've talked to the
hydro industry about how important the
recks are to them
so sure and and I will just note and
it's a very good question and and I
think we'll we could probably get you
the actual sort of breakdown of what
percentage of uh the obligation is met
through renewable energy certificates
versus uh through alternative compliance
payments so that's something we can
provide for the committee um you know
when it comes to the Economic
Development question I'm I'm just going
to say you know our job is to administer
the program and make it happen right you
know it's up to the legislature to
determine you know what all of those uh
values and benefits are that that uh you
know you get from the program and and
they're obviously State energy or excuse
me state agencies that um are focused on
on you know like the Department of
Business and economic Affairs you know
we've heard from dncr uh in the past on
biomass specific bills um you know that
Economic Development question is an
important one it's one that is not
necessarily one that falls within the
the purview of the Department of energy
in
administering um the program because we
aren't we aren't just sort of like
picking you know this is what the
obligation is uh you know 25.2 that's
obviously something that the legislature
has has done for us so I I do have the
the comfortable position of saying it
really is up to to you guys to determine
what the what the benefits going to be
um but yeah no uh going back to what the
goal is it really is you know the RPS is
designed to be either that that missing
money or that additional Financial
incentive towards generating resources
uh that might not otherwise be
economical right so we're we're
providing money because you know if you
just had to compete in the market these
are resources that might not be selected
at least that's the argument that folks
are are are making so um if you have a
you know uh a Rec you know trading for
$25 a megawatt hour or something like
that uh that's an extra $25 that that's
going to help make that resource
economical um you know we've heard a lot
of conversation when it comes to biomass
right that you know there are those
benefits uh for economic development
that you know in the timber industry um
you know for Trucking and for all of
those sort of like uh Downstream
businesses that help turn you know wood
into electricity um it's it's not it is
a state concern but the department of
Energy's Focus really is to administer
the program uh as we've been instructed
by the legislature a very brief followup
just a very simple question um so the
simple follow-up would be does the
department of energy still look at
Supply diversity as one of the goals
that we have in the
state sure
yes representative Corman thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question actually
uh have two questions first one is
looking at the chart that's up there we
see a big drop in
2023 for the uh cost of Rex uh the total
cost and I'm wondering uh was that
because there's an increased Supply or
something else second question is how
closely are individual wrecks tracked I
have uh a solar array at my house I'm
selling recks I sell them to a
broker and and I don't really know what
happens to them after that I don't know
if they're being retired within the
state or not within the state um how is
my wreck tracked through the
system so I'm going to answer that in
reverse order so right so you take your
individual individual recks from your
solar rate right you've I've sort of
left this part out but right there are
these Brokers that exist that will
collect all these Recs from um whether
it's from large facilities or small
smaller facilities like yourselves um
and bundle them so they're easier for
these suppliers to actually buy an
aggregate rather than say okay well
representative Corman I'm going to buy
your three wrecks I'm going to buy two
recks here right and they're going
through the whole
process um so those wrecks um are then
once they are um uh aggregated they're
then sold um to one of those electricity
suppliers somewhere in New England so
your wreck in theory um could be uh
settled in Connecticut so they could say
okay well I've purchased this wreck even
though it's from New Hampshire um it
means
the the qualifications for I'm making up
a number here but a class one wreck in
Connecticut we're going to retire them
say it's uh ever Source I'm they're
going to purchase it and they're going
to retire in
Connecticut there's a system called uh
knole GIS which if anybody uh is
involved in like mapping at the local
level it's different than the gis system
that's used for mapping it's a slightly
different it's a different thing but it
has the same acronym um there's uh so
there are individual that all of that
gets logged in that system so they know
that your w are only sold once and then
from you to the supplier uh to the um
excuse me to the the um broker excuse me
thank you um and then sold once from the
broker to the um supplier of electricity
and then retired so they basically
there's they're tracked all the way
through the system um regarding the drop
in 2023 um it's Confluence of a number
of factors um mostly it's just a uh the
ACP it's sort of hard to tell from this
did come down a little bit um over prior
years um but the record costs um just
increase Supply and then there's always
policy decisions made by other states
that then influence the trading of those
Recs across the
region representative Summers has your
question thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question um I'm
actually looking at just quickly that
looking at the different classes of Rex
and I know as of last year um because
we're in ISO New England our neighbor to
the South Massachusetts basically had
taken our whole entire class three there
and has passed a law stating that class
3 is bad for the environment so now they
no longer include that in their RPS just
wanted to add that in as a note secondly
I noticed that um multiple states in the
United States um view because of the
time the visionable material Burns and
all BLS and also it's the that multiple
states were uh view nuclear power as a
renewable product would legislation be
be needed to a Define nuclear power as a
Renewable Power and secondly to add it
as one of the classes on
here yes we uh are the classes are are
determined by
Statute representative
parial thank you chair I'd feel remous
if I didn't ask about the practice uh
that many people in the state consider
uh distorting our recom Mark and that is
the practice of Rec sweeping um to avoid
alternative compliance payments could
you speak to that a little
bit in terms of the process or the
policy
or more the process and whether or not
policy is uh uh needed to circum to uh
clean up that process we are looking at
a review as you said in Du 2025 is this
a good time to examine that as
well so that is a separate process um I
don't know if it would necessarily be oh
uh I would have to go back and look at
the actual statute to specify whether it
it requests us to look at that
particular aspect um for for the the
larger committee this the idea of Rec
sweeping essentially it's a um a
settlement process um by which uh there
are a number of of smaller suppliers I'm
going to use representative Corman for
example where if they decide it is not
worth their time or their effort to
register with neol GIS in order to
actually generate and sell those wrecks
uh excuse me to Mint those wrecks excuse
me um they've opted not to do that
process and it can be a long process um
for something that may be worth 20ish
dollars depending on the size of AR Ray
um so there are some folks who just opt
not to do it um as part of the statute
um of course we've touched briefly on
net metering um as those uh utility uh
companies are purchasing that uh
electricity that's generated back or
netting it against um your um purchasing
the exports then crediting it against
any of your Imports of electricity to
get that netting that happens um the
statute allows them to essentially to um
acquire those renewable energy
certificates now there's a question of
and then use them in order to um meet
the demand excuse me meet the
requirements of Class 2 um in New
Hampshire um there is a question I know
this has been debated multiple times in
front of this committee before um you
can either do it one you can do it the
other way this avoids double counting of
recks so they're not going to two places
at the same time so we know that they're
being done once um the other option um
there have been a variety of different
legislative uh attempts to change this
policy um it would be really the purview
of the legislature as to whether or not
um those wrecks how to handle those
wrecks at the end of the day
representative Wendy Thomas thank you Mr
chair um
thank you for being here Joshua you did
a really good job explaining this um to
use your example about wrecks um if a
wreck cost $50 and an ACP and we're just
using it as an example cost
55 it's theoretical that during an
auction some recks will not be
purchased what happens to those wrecks
if they're not purchased are they rolled
over or do they die a of untimely death
uh that's a very good question so um the
Rex uh themselves um if the ACP uh sorry
let me back up so in that scenario where
the actual trading price of the wreck is
$55 and the ACP is 50 it means that one
of the other states around us the the
whatever their ACP value is higher so it
makes more sense for I will use I'm not
trying to pick on eversource but I know
they operate in three states in the
region they've decided that um a wreck
they may have purchased they could
either um retire in Connecticut or they
could retire to New Hampshire and say
the ACP is much higher in Connecticut it
makes more sense to pay the ACP here and
retire the wreck in Connecticut um
utilities are also allowed to bank
wrecks um so for example if they um over
buy or something like that happens um
they're allowed to carry them forward to
the next year um I believe it's a limit
up to 20% of their obligation I will
need to double check on that yeah okay
people behind me are nodding yes um that
they can carry those forward um as far
as an
expiration dat two years years okay yes
uh So within two years of gener two
years of being minted excuse me thank
you thank you very
much representative
rolds thank you Mr chairman thanks again
guys for being here and taking my
question um I just wanted to ask you um
rather directly about if whether you
have uh data or just a feeling e some
explanation or whether or a theory uh if
you could to what do you attribute when
you look at the graph that we've had the
compliance costs of uh the
RPS um up to 2023 you know you see a
peak in 2019 and then since then uh what
I would call a pretty precipitous drop
you know down down uh small Rebound in
2022 but then a big drop so if you draw
a line from 2019 to 2023 there's almost
a
you know we call it a 45% looks like
Drop in compliance
costs to what do you attribute
that so as mentioned previously there's
a there's a regional Rec excuse me a
regional market for Rex um it's hard to
say pinpoint exactly what what thing
happened where to sort of drop it um but
it is it's a larger Regional phenomenon
where there' just been more recks that
would be available so they'd be able to
be purchased at a lower cost um and
therefore um reduced compliance
cost well and yeah and obviously the uh
the reduction in class three we have not
done that uh that's been a more recent
um uh development as as sort of just
sort of the biomass Market has evolved
and so that would uh be responsible uh
for for part of the part of the
change okay thank you okay
representative B has a question thank
you chairman uh this is more of a
clarification question this chart
doesn't say that this is for New
Hampshire but uh understanding that this
is for New Hampshire that might Explain
how other states might um compensate
some of the cost
so yeah yeah for sure so this is New
Hampshire specific if you look at
Massachusetts with their um their
variety they have different they have
you know three or four different
programs that are you know there's a
clean energy standard there's a
renewable portfolio standard there's a
clean Peak standard all sorts of things
like that their total cost and the last
time I saw data I think it was from 2022
they were a little behind on on where
they were but they had projected their
cost between a billion 1.5 billion
dollars uh per year in Massachusetts so
there's obviously a significant scale
associated with with other states and
obviously you know with their five times
uh our size so that's that's going to
get baked into it but even accounting
for that fact they have a pretty
significant spend on on these types of
programs representative
Swanson thank you Mr
chair
uh despite having my background in Astro
engineering and sometimes being called a
space cadet I am very impressed with the
uh kind of the the fundamental
accounting details behind all this but
uh I think it's kind of been asked and
maybe addressed but can and I'm looking
at so this has been a period of 15 years
this has been going
on uh and and how has this do you feel
like this has changed the mix of energy
production in the state of New Hampshire
in that 15
years it's a good question and it's one
that I'm I you know I i' probably want
to talk to some folks in the agency
before you know attributing success to
to one resource or another over the last
20 years we've seen a significant change
in the resource mix uh most of that
we've seen through the the uh change
from oil and coal as being you know
primary and and certainly significant
resources to to Natural Gas being the
the the you know Top Dog uh in New
England uh most of that has been driven
not necessarily by policy as much as it
has been by economics and that's just
because natural gas uh especially with
the sort of prevalence of you know the
Marcel Shale uh kind of explosion around
the time that this went into effect uh
we saw uh a significant um price uh
dampening from that and that made
natural natural gas a much more
economical resource um obviously State
policy um both for RPS and in other
areas of of decarbonization that we've
seen throughout New England you know our
resource mix in 20 years could look very
different than it does today and I think
that's the goal of of a lot of folks um
how much I'm going to attribute that to
RPS specifically in New Hampshire i' I'd
love to get back to you especially I
know you have a number of bills on this
topic and uh you'll you'll certainly
hear her from us
then okay gentlemen I want to thank you
very much for being here an excellent
presentation as always from the
department and at this point in time
we're going to take a lunch break and we
will come back at 1:00 to hear from the
Public Utilities Commission Now during
our orientation hour between 9 and 10 I
had suggested that we would talk about
public hearings and executive sessions
but we ran out of time and did not have
that discussion so we will have that
discussion at a future date we could
talk about it this afternoon if the
committee has the energy to hang out and
talk about it or we could uh bring that
up maybe next week before we start some
public hearings we'll have that
discussion uh at the end of the
day
pardon we do uh so maybe we should have
that discussion today if we if we if we
have if we have a chance if we have the
energy uh and the stamina so anyway go
get some lunch and we'll see you all
back here at 1:00 thank you
oh
e
e e
please make your way to your seat
everyone we'll resume here shortly e
okay it is one o'clock and we have some
very busy people who have joined us this
afternoon and I don't want to waste any
of their time so we're going to jump
right into a presentation by the Public
Utilities Commission um like to welcome
the Commissioners to the committee and
turn it over to the chair to make a
presentation thank you thank you
chairman V good afternoon and thank you
to the chairman and the SD committee for
the opportunity to present to you
today um on the first page
we um this is the agenda as as uh as
asked for by chairman Vose I'll give a
brief introduction and
overview commissioner Del arano will go
through the puc process and then
commissioner chetto PTI we'll go over
rate based State and Regional
proceedings and then we'll we'll wrap
up so without any further Ado I'll get
started just briefly as U as a bio I'm
Dan goldner I've been the chair for the
last three years and was a commissioner
for about six months before that I spent
30 years in the defense and
semiconductor businesses um beginning as
a design engineer I moved on to program
management and eventually became the
Vice President of Finance and operations
at Texas
Instruments and um have worked all over
I've lived in Texas I've lived in
California I lived in Oso Norway for
three years and spent the last 10 years
on down at Manchester on Granite
Street um and I finally I have a
Bachelor of Science mechanical
engineering and an
NBA so without any further Ado uh going
to the first slide uh this is sort of a
picture of what we regulate at the Pu so
it's about7 billion doll in assets about
two billion in annual revenue so there's
a lot of uh a lot of money in this
business the chart to your upper left is
a
picture of the electric utilities uh the
picture to the upper right is the Gas
Utilities the chart on the bottom shows
that ever sources is about 80% of the
customer base uh here in New Hampshire
and the Liberty has about 73% of the gas
customers here in New Hampshire and off
to the right is a list of the regulated
Water Systems the list of sewer
utilities and then a brief note on our
very limited engagement in
Telecom all right right so you know why
do we need a pu is the next
question um so we we're really about
checks and balances so
monopolies um don't have competition
they can exploit their Market Power by
charging excessively high prices they
can limit output they can reduce the
quality of goods and services and they
can hinder
Innovation so you know ultimately this
harms consumers and the overall economy
our powers are delegated from the US
Constitution and ultimately ly the um
the legislature here in New Hampshire
under article 83 and I've provided here
just a brief history of Monopoly
regulation in New Hampshire which really
for the Pu starts in
1911 and uh we changed our name in
1951 and so this regulation in gas
electric and water in Telecom has been
going on for over a 100
years on the next slide I called it old
versus new PU
and this is the legislative changes from
July
2021 for those of you that were here
then and just as a brief recap uh the
old commission was three Commissioners
nine divisions more than 70 people and a
wide variety of
functions staff of the PC proferred
positions to the Commissioners in each
docket staff negotiated settlements with
the utilities the OCA and the special
interests outside of the of the
adjudicative process and presented to
the commission for approve
approval and you know with adjudication
policy audit and enforcement in a single
organization there could be the
appearance of impropriety the same folks
that are negotiating the deal the same
organization that's negotiating the deal
is also approving the deal so the
legislature responded to that in 2021 by
splitting off the doe and making the
commission a separate independent and
firewalled uh organization to ensure
impartial and neutral decision-making
the due at that same time was spun off
per RSA 12p and is an automatic party to
all
proceedings and uh is to provide the
commission with independent information
on the record used to render reasoned
sound and fair decisions I know there's
some legislation that talks about uh
different responsibilities for the doe
the only thing we at the PC would
suggest is just to uh think about a
counterparty to the Monopoly whoever
that is whether that's in the doe or the
AG's office or in the commission itself
whatever it is there just needs to be a
counterparty to the
Monopoly and then finally and I'll show
an or chart in a minute there's three
Commissioners and 12 people so we're
much smaller than the old old
pu all right next slide um there's been
some discussion about the differences
between the Pu and a court and so I
thought I I just put together a very
brief slide on what are the differences
and what are people talking about when
they talk about the PC versus the court
so first the easy one the the courts are
part of the judicial branch and the PC's
part of the Executive Branch the courts
interpret the
laws the PC enforces the public
utilities laws the courts have broad
jurisdiction the PC has narrow
jurisdiction just to the public
utilities the court have broad Equity
Powers the Pu has very narrow Equity
powers and finally and probably the most
important one is that typically the
court has no interest in the outcome of
civil litigation where the puc ACT is
the Arbiter between the interest of the
customer in the interests of the
regulated utilities so that's really the
difference uh between the two uh the two
entities and uh the other is also some
discussion on settlements um who should
be settlements who has you know who has
the power in the settlements these kinds
of things and so what we wanted to
highlight here is just that the courts
you a civil action are governed by
contract
law um the parties are free to settle
any case on any terms they choose and in
the end the parties pay as a result of
uh the
process in the Public Utilities
Commission a settlement is neither a
contract nor governed by contract
law instead it's stipulated findings of
fact in inclusions of law so we're doing
something quite different than the court
system again we're the Arbiter of the
interests of customers and the interest
of the
utilities we must thoroughly review each
settlement to assess whether it's
consistent with the public
interest and uh our authority to approve
or reject settlements is a necessary
Safeguard against unwise or improper
settlements and then finally right
settlements really except but for the
utilities use other people's money civil
litigation it's just the two parties
involved in the case of the Pu other
people's money is
involved all right next slide is just a
simple or chart for the commission we're
a small entity organization there's just
three Commissioners and then there's 12
staff um and and the SEC administrator
per the uh change in the law last year
at the SEC administrator moved to the
puc so that makes a total of
13 and on the next slide you'll see our
operational forers so we tracked these
metrics to see how we're doing there was
a lot of criticism and it was justified
of the Commission in 2021 and early 2022
that things were going into the
commission but weren't coming out and
that was true we only had a handful of
people there it was a new organization
we were trying to get things up and
running and so you can see the output in
2022 as we caught up on decisional
orders was 195 decisional orders that's
an alltime record in the PC for all the
records that we have they go back maybe
20 or 25 years things have now steadied
out we're outputting now about 165
orders a
year um the also on this chart you'll
see orders of notice those are letting
folks know that we have upcoming
hearings procedural orders those are
usually calendaring scheduling and so
forth um old dockets closed we try to
keep track of are we on top of old
dockets are we processing things in a
timely fashion and then finally the days
from filing to acknowledgement letter
are we getting back with people quickly
and efficiently so that everyone knows
and is getting responded to so with that
I'll pause uh before we move to
commissioner Delano I committed to give
a brief overview of 10 minutes so that's
what I've tried to
do excellent thank you pass the
microphone over to uh commissioner d
orano by the way it's nice to um meet
you never met you here before nice to
meet you as B representative uh excuse
me uh so I am the newest commissioner uh
on the commission uh on page 10 you'll
see a a very short bio about myself I
put on there since uh we're all meeting
each other for the first time uh I am
the uh attorney commissioner on the
commission uh under statute uh you know
one of the Commissioners must be an
attorney uh and that falls to me uh I
had uh previous to the commission worked
at the attorney General's office as an
Assistant Attorney General prior to that
I was uh at shenin and before that I was
in uh industry as in-house
Council next slide
please in the energy realm there are
really two primary Regulators there are
the state and the federal government and
the federal government's regulation of
the El of electricity is really wrapped
up in the interstate commerce clause to
the Constitution as well as the what I
like to call the uh most powerful law
that no one's ever heard of the federal
power act and so under the federal power
act uh FK has jurisdiction furk is the
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission has
jurisdiction over the use or sale of
electric energy in interstate commerce
applying to the transmission of electric
energy in interstate commerce into the
sale of electric energy at wholesale in
interstate commerce the key to all of
that being interstate commerce on the
other hand the states they regulate all
of the intrastate Commerce in other
words if you have a dis a distribution
utility and they're selling to local
rate uh local rate payers or
customers the state is responsible for
the regulation of that aspect of the
transaction there is though an exception
under federal law for rates that must be
just and reasonable and if a state isn't
adequately making sure that that is
happening then F can actually change
change uh some State regulation but it
almost never
does and the next page uh page 12 uh
I've given some examples of some of the
uh the jurisdiction that the commission
has um I'm not going to read through the
entire list but uh at towards the bottom
of the second column you'll see rate
proceedings and tariff adjustments
that's a a big part of what we do uh we
review integrated distribution plans uh
we deal with the limited electrical
energy uh producers act uh and also net
metering and as I said I won't uh bore
you all with the
list um turning to the next slide on
page
13 uh we just wanted to highlight for
you folks what the New Hampshire energy
policy currently is now this is what's
in statute this is the policy that the
Pu um is required to follow uh and I
won't read it for you now but um it it
really tries to balance the needs of the
rate base versus those of the regulated
utilities and in doing so the the
legislator has decided that we need to
look at a uh you know diverse uh sources
of energy which uh in my mind is just a
good thing anyway uh and other demands
side resources to protect the safety and
health of the citizens uh the physical
environment of the state and the future
supplies of resources so what does all
that mean uh basically that means that
energy needs to be delivered safely
reliably and uh environmentally in an
environmentally sensitive manner so uh
some of those responsibilities are now
uh with the Department of energy but the
Pu Pu needs to regulate the rates that
these utilities will uh seek in order to
keep these systems up to keep those
resources safe reliable and uh to
protect the
environment uh the next page uh 14 uh
commission jurisdiction protection of
consumers so uh the the puc has a very
important role in protecting um
consumers from some of the uh Monopoly
powers that uh that that uh the public
utilities have in other words uh there's
kind of What's called the regulatory
compact where you have um a public
utility that requires some kind of rate
of return on its money uh you have the
ability under a monopoly uh situation
for a uh company like that to charge
whatever they want for their products
are the only supplier of it as part of
the regulatory compact
the state through its
pu balances the interests of the rate
payer in paying the lowest rate possible
with the interests of the uh regulated
Monopoly in ensuring that one it makes a
reasonable rate of return on its assets
and uh secondly that uh the capital
structure that is ultimately approved by
the the Public Utilities Commission will
allow that regulated utility to continue
to operate that's a very important point
that a lot of folks Miss in utility
regulation that you know at the end of
the day uh we're a cap on uh their
spending and on their return but we also
ensure a floor so that that way they can
uh yeah stay solvent and continue to
operate uh next page uh page 15 uh I
wanted to give you guys a bit of an
example of what a commission proceeding
looks like like so uh this is uh almost
a this is my uh depiction of what our
hearing room looks like at the
Pu uh on one side we have the public
utility and they generally bring the
most people and so they're depicted in
Blue on the other side uh we have the
department of energy depicted in yellow
the office of the consumer Advocate
depicted in green and uh what we're
calling interveners but the
traditionally stakeholders in uh utility
regulation uh depicted in purple and so
I'm next I'm going to go through some of
the roles that all of the that these
parties play in uh you know in these
functions uh we're going to skip slide
16 because this is more of something I
provided for all of you it's almost a
cheat sheet to how to read one of our uh
dockets um you know what the numbers
mean and some examples of of cases that
fall under those kinds of dockets so if
we move on to uh page 17
the Pu basically has two types of
proceedings before one of them one type
is adjudicative proceedings uh those are
proceedings that are almost like a mini
trial at the administrative
level and we have non- adjudicative
processes which are and this is actually
shown on page 18 the next slide and
nonadjudicated processes which
essentially Encompass just about
everything else now the kinds of matters
that we hear in adjudicative proceedings
are generally things like rate cases uh
utility financing uh Alternative forms
of Regulation uh but it also can include
things like procurement of renewable
natural
gas whereas administr non- adjudicative
processes they include things like uh
review of uh you know Community Power
electric aggregation plan so these are
plans that the town's put together for
aggregation and they are reviewed and
approved by the Public Utilities
Commission this doesn't generally end up
in some kind of contested matter
although if there was interest in a cont
in this turning into a contested case
the Pu could if it felt that it was in
the interest of the public convert this
into an utive proceeding but so far the
puc hasn't had anything like that uh
also we do investigation of Interstate
rates through non- adjudicative process
we do our rul making and uh declaratory
rulings declaratory rulings are
generally requests from folks that are
regulated by a state agency looking to
see how a rule or statute might apply to
them so that isn't unlike a declaratory
judgment in court where there would be
two sides here this is generally someone
coming and asking the commission uh you
know what how they think this rule might
apply to them and the commission will
come out with a ruling uh the attorney
Attorney General's office is usually
involved with that as well so um it's
not something that the commission will
make on its own it'll generally ask the
Attorney General's office for an opinion
on the matter and take that opinion and
uh weigh it against the statutory
obligations commission
has we turn to the next page 19
commission is Arbiter uh chair goldner
uh started speaking a bit about this
unlike a court uh the commission is
really the Arbiter between the interests
of the consumer and the interest of the
regulated utility this isn't just
something that we say this is actually
uh in statute uh it's been in statute
since I want to say uh at the earliest
the late
1960s uh and hasn't changed very much uh
since
then turn to the next page uh I've
highlighted some statements from the
Supreme Court and from our statutes uh
regarding that position of arbiter so uh
in appeal of pin Tre power uh the state
supreme court decided that in
determining rates the Pu isbd between
the interests of the customer and the
interests of the regulated
utility uh when considering whether to
allow a regulated utility to recover
electric distribution system investment
costs from rate payers the commission
must first determine whether those
Investments were prudently incurred this
is where we get into the used and useful
analysis that the commission goes
through uh when it's adjudicating rate
cases uh in determining whether rates
are adjusted reasonable commission must
balance the customer's interest in
paying no higher rates
uh than are required against the
Investor's interest in obtaining a
reasonable rate of return on their
Investments this is uh again something
that we discussed or at least I
discussed a little bit earlier uh and
then lastly uh the Pu must not only
perform duties statutorily created but
also exercise those powers inherent with
it within its broad Grant of power so
unlike most state agencies and most
adjudicative proceedings the uh one one
example of this is that uh the uh Public
Utilities Commission can reopen an old
order with notice and provide for due
process and reexamine that order if
things have changed in the future most
administrative agencies in fact I can't
think of one that has that exact same
power but the puc has that power in
order to make sure that rates are just
and reasonable and in the public
interest uh we turn next page please 21
uh commission as investigator uh so
without going through both of these here
uh the commission has a limited role as
an investigator in other words uh it has
a legal responsibility uh you know to
make sure that uh you know before
holding a hearing that it investigates
the uh matters that will be uh before it
during the hearing and um if they rely
on facts that uh came from that
investigation that they're included in
the hearing record and included uh in
the order if those were used as part of
that
decision uh in terms of rate increases
uh the Pu has uh investigatory Authority
there as well uh and this is again to
make sure that rates are just reasonable
and in the public
interest turn to the next page uh we're
now turning to our uh public utility our
group of uh blue tables uh what is a
public utility I won't uh read the
definition but I provided it there for
folks um so that they understand you
know what is what is a public utility
and the kinds of businesses that have to
come before the
Pu uh turning to the next page page 23
again with blue tables uh I've included
you know a couple of different types of
proceedings so we have rate increases um
that a public utility May file with
their schedules when they open up a new
rate case and we also talk a little bit
about the burden that the public utility
must meet in order to uh to have a rate
increase uh and so you know this this
process is is is very clearly delineated
in statute so uh there's never an
opportunity for the Pu to just kind of
make it up it this is all things that uh
the legislature has established and uh
processes that we follow based on those
established uh statutory
Provisions uh turning to the next page I
also provideed an example of uh
franchise expansions these are when uh a
public utility wants to either uh expand
into a new business or increase its uh
service territory uh it can also be when
new entrants want to come into uh New
Hampshire and uh be a uh public utility
uh and again uh you know there's a
statutory burden of proof on uh what
these utilities must substantiate in
order for the Pu to issue an order
allowing the expansion of of the
franchise these get a lot shorter pretty
soon here so uh next page is 25 uh
talked a little bit about the department
of Energy's role uh in our proceedings
uh the department of energy is an
automatic party to all commission
proceedings uh it also has the authority
to petition for any proceeding before
the public utilties commission so what
this means is that any of the uh list of
areas that uh we talked a little bit
about earlier on the two columns uh in
some instances uh the department of
energy can petition and affirm
affirmatively bring something forward to
the Public Utilities Commission to
consider um while before the Public
Utilities Commission uh the department
represents the Department's position in
commission
proceedings uh it has the authority to
investigate any matter that may come
before the
commission and lastly uh it must provide
all necessary administrative Technical
and staff support the commission to
assist the Commission in carrying out
its Regulatory and adjudicative
functions so uh the when the puc had 70
employees as you can imagine uh it had a
lot more support than it does under a
scheme where there's 13 employees and so
uh when the legislature made the
decision to split doe away from uh the
Public Utilities Commission left this
caveat or or this requirement in the law
so that uh uh you know we're we're not
uh left up a creek without a paddle so
to speak and we can uh both receive at
hearings information from uh the
department of energy but also outside of
hearings they also manage our business
office it's actually their business
office that we use as an
administratively attached
agency uh turning to the next page uh I
talked a little bit about the consumer
Advocate uh in New Hampshire our
consumer Advocate is the consumer
advocate for residential rate payers uh
and he has a pretty important job in
that role um you know they he is
supposed to uh uh petition or initiate
for initiate proceedings before the
Public Utilities Commission regarding
matters that involve uh rate payer
interests and again I by that I mean
residential rate payer interests um and
uh the second point on that page States
his St has standing to intervene in
commission proceedings only when the
interests of residential utility
customers are presently involved uh and
that's that's something that came from
uh the Supreme Court essentially what
that means is that if we're having a
rate case that's only commercial rates
uh or rate distribution rates for
commercial clients uh or commercial
customers uh of a utility then uh the
consumer Advocate doesn't have a role in
that uh kind of proceeding because those
rate payers are not residential rate
payers uh moving on to uh page 27 uh are
interveners uh those interveners can
include among others uh customers
investors in investor owned utilities
industry groups uh uh clean energy New
Hampshire comes to mind immediately uh
non-governmental organizations similar
uh New Hampshire subdivisions towns
counties uh other state
agencies uh independent power producers
independent energy suppliers and any
other person with an interest in a
pending case uh prospective interveners
must uh petition the commission to
intervene in a commission proceeding
meaning that you know they're not
automatic parties uh and that uh in most
cases they're not even mandatory parties
they're what's called a permissive party
so if they can articulate a an interest
that should be heard before the Public
Utilities Commission the Public
Utilities Commission will grant
intervention to those folks
uh and the commission may impose
conditions upon uh interveners
participation in the proceedings either
at the time of intervention or at any
subsequent time uh and so a lot of times
uh although I haven't seen it with the
current commission uh past commissions
have put uh you know relatively
reasonable restrictions on um large
groups of interveners for instance
they've got to get get together and do
Discovery together or they have to get
together and and uh present a position
together uh again that isn't something
this commission to my knowledge has ever
done that wraps up my
section okay please pass the microphone
over to commissioner
chat so good afternoon um just a quick
background I have a PhD in
economics and um I've been
doing uh utility
regulations um since
1999 and um initially I was um you know
I got my PhD from University of
Washington Seattle and I went back to
India worked as a consultant and then
moved to a electricity Regulatory
Commission as their uh their only
Economist okay um I have
also um I was the assistant consumer
Advocate I think beginning sorry um yeah
sometimes beginning 2015 through all the
way to 2021 when I joined the
commission
um uh of late I'm also um involved in
Regional electric matters and I was uh
selected by uh nuk to represent uh the
New England interest um so there were
two Commissioners that were chosen in
this Pan national effort to look at how
we can improve um the interplay between
different states uh impacting
transmission gas electric coordination
all of that so that is a FK States
collaboration and I'm part of it um so
I'm going to now dive into the the
slides um as should be apparent from the
previous um discussions it's um we have
a a significant role in setting rates
and the goal for us to do it do that in
a just and reasonable manner that's
that's the main focus and um much of the
um the most important dockets usually
tend to be the rate cases so right now
we have couple of rate cases
ongoing um though I I cannot talk about
them um but they take up a lot of of our
our time in understanding what is being
proposed and you know again meeting our
statutory role
um the other types of rates are also
very important so if you go to the next
slide um I've mentioned some of the
rates that we look at and um I'd like
to stress that given the change in the
competitive environment you have now
Community power you have a lot more uh
competitive ener energy Supply the
default service rate has taken greater
importance and been starting we've
started taking a look at it um so it's
not merely restricting the Monopoly
power of the regulated utilities it's
also looking at um fostering a
competitive environment and that
requires that we look at what's going on
in other rates and and and we have been
um uh guiding the default rates in a
particular manner off late and I'm going
to talk about it in the next
slide just
a so for a reference if if if folks want
to take a look at a particular utility
you can go back and look at what's going
on in docket D 23043 and docket de 2446
um the
um so for for example for February 20125
to July
2025 the commission has directed
eversource for example to self procure
30% of its expected residential load so
what's what the commission has done
we've started looking at data and we've
come to the realization that the U the
100% purchase of power from other third
party suppliers tags on a big um premium
okay with the the rate pays have been
paying and it tends to be that looking
at historical data that they pay a lot
more than what they would if they were
at least partly buying on their own
directly talking about utilities um
looking at the markets at any point in
time and and purchasing power that would
that would save a lot of money for
residential customers
um you go to slide don't see the number
sorry um this
one that's slide
3 32 slide 32 I'm I'm trying to um oh
you're there okay yeah so um I just
wanted to highlight
here that um I looked at the data and
the markups between what the Wholesale
Electric market prices turn out to be as
opposed to what the rates tend to be in
the um the um default service they the
markups are given here for the different
months August 23 to November 24 of
course when you have very high energy
prices you'll see the markups are really
high and when when the um uh Energy
prices are low the markups are not that
high but they're still pretty
substantial so for example in November
20 2024 the number is
60 3% and so it's still pretty high so
um and so that's that's the message that
I wanted to capture here even though you
can also infer that over time with the
move from 100% procurement from third
party to partly
self-supply right now ever s has 12 1
12% of its energy needs being met
through self-supply so if they do that
that also probably impacted this trend
so you see here but it's not as clear as
what would appear in the next slide Mr
chairman Mr
chairman I I know we usually wait for
questions but I just wondered if at this
moment we could ask the commissioner to
explain what self Supply is I don't I'm
certainly not familiar certainly sure
yeah so the
utility not running an RFP so for
example if they want to procure energy
in
February they will buy energy based on
the spot market prices or whatever the
real prices are at that time so that's
self-supply they're
not SP but I hesitate to use that term
strictly because there are other
elements to
it um so going to slide number
33 you will notice that since
July
um
2023 when the rate pairs residential
rate pairs in New in New Hampshire paid
the highest price relative to the other
um you know other states
their
prices in
October
2024 was the lowest among the divested
States okay so that's the red line if
you look at it was at the highest in
July 2023 and it's lowest except for
Vermont in October
2024 so why am I pointing out except
Vermont because Vermont isn't the divest
state so they have it's they're not in
in the markets like the other states
are so that tells me that this move
towards bidin Cod self Supply is
helping and um
if based on what is expected in the
early part of
2025 I would expect the electric rates
in New Hampshire to go even lower
representative McGee would like to
interrupt with a question thank you uh
thank you Mr commissioner for taking my
question so are we to assume that that's
the
only input to lowering those prices
because I know we've increased
competition in that same period of time
with Community power driving prices down
as well right some competition in the
market that is correct so that's why um
even for the previous slides even though
you see a trend we cannot be 100% sure
it's just about one specific input and
likewise for this graph yes but I'm just
saying you know this this is a
significant change from what happened in
July 2023 to October and part of it is
maybe we are already seeing some
benefits of moving to um the self Supply
yes go ahead
please Ju Just to further um add on to
commissioner trap's comments we what we
know is that in the last cycle the
wholesale price with all of the
additions and everything added in was
about $65 a megawatt hour for
Supply the uh distribution
utilities are sellings to the market
price beginning February 1st varies
between $83 a megawatt hour and $89 a
megawatt hour and had we gone um to the
the old process had we just um had we
just gone through the third party
bidding process the price would have
been about $100 a megawatt hour so we we
we know we know what's uh happening as
we go and uh if we were able to get to
the 100% wholesale price it would be
about $65 a megawatt hour
so to the point
about other things happening in the
market in terms of competition the last
um point in
slide 3
34 it's the the great this is important
as in for for for an economist so
greater Reliance on self Supply
potentially also supports greater retail
competition between competitive energy
suppliers community power aggregators
and utilities with pricing signals Sands
unnecessary risk
premiums slide
35 um I'll just quickly go over like
there are other mechanism that can help
lead to a more competitive outcome and
view you know this I I won't go over
them um Point by point but uh the
important thing here is that there is
also a linkage between between what do
you see in the retail markets and what
do you see in wholesale markets and you
if you want to better link the retail
markets with the wholesale markets to
get to a more competitive outcome
okay
and so now I'm going to slightly change
the discussion a bit this is more about
our role in the regional uh landscape
okay okay so slide number
36 shows how in the US you have
different
Ros and New Hampshire is part of the iso
New England RTO
okay and it it based on the statute it
is up to us to represent the interest of
New Hampshire rirs uh customers um it's
it's it's it's in the statute so it's
it's we have a role in ensuring that
first of all the policies that are there
in the in in the state policies are
being consistently adad to um when we
participate in Regional activities and
number two it's as as an economist it's
really about uh getting the benefits of
competition that's that's what drives my
way of looking at
things so quickly um there are two major
players in the regional uh Arena it's
obviously for us it's the iso New
England and it's FK ISO New England is
uh answerable to FK so those are the two
major entities but there are other
entities that we get involved in so that
we can impress upon ISO New England or F
what is right for us and those
um Regional bodies are represented in
um page 39 okay so there are three
major um players one of them is necar
and that's the Commissioners are part of
it the second is Nesco they get involved
in knee poool matters before ISO New
England so they um for different
comedies in in neol have representation
from Nesco and I'm not talking about
voting rights I'm just saying they're
present there to let them know what the
states
think and lastly nuk which is a National
Organization um of the regulated utility
Commissioners there too we have a role
and so the initially when I was
introducing myself I talked about U this
collaboration between FK and states that
was started by nuk and I'm part of it
so again going back to the so if you go
back to go to slide 40 I'm stressing the
importance of linking retail competition
with wholesale competition so I
personally believe that um there is a
role
for us in improving participant
participation by end customers here
in the state um in wholesale Market
activities so that they can also benefit
from It generally what happens is the
Wholesale Electric markets given ISO New
England's focus on transmission and
other things they tend to uh be more
Guided by you know how they can get
supply cheaply but so it that thrust
kind of misses the point that even rate
pairs at the as end end users retail
customers can benefit from the wholesale
markets directly by participating
through um demand response so that is
something that I'm also part of there's
a working group that I'm participating
in so I wanted to hurry a little bit
because of the time constraints thank
you well thank you uh to the three of
you I have to say I've sat through quite
a few quite a number of
pu presentations in the past and this
one was by far the best I have sat
through you uh gentlemen have compiled
an
excellent handbook if you will of
matters that members of this committee
can use as reference as we do our work
on the legislative side in the upcoming
year so I want to thank all three of you
for the hard work you've put into this
presentation and uh commend you on its
on its Excellence than you now I know we
have a um a presentation scheduled by
the New England Power gener Association
at 2 o'cl but I'm going to allow
questions for as long as the committee
has them to these Commissioners while we
have them here because um we don't get a
chance to talk to you guys very often so
representative Bernardi will start us
off thank you Mr chairman so uh
Pennsylvania sits on world's largest
supply of uh natural gas and yet we are
foreclosed from getting additional
natural gas here because New York and
Massachusetts have passed laws saying
you may not expand or add additional
pipelines you talked about Cooperative
uh agreements and and opportunities with
uh working with other Commissioners and
working with FK is there an opportunity
anywhere in there for you to make the
case uh through those organizations that
the upcoming Department of Justice ought
to bring suit against uh those states to
stop that uh violation of interstate
commerce or any other opportunity for
opening up gas pipeline service to New
England on the first part not being a
lawyer I'm not going to risk commenting
on it but um but um as far
as um trying to get the benefits of um
access to gas
markets um that is
um something that personally even in the
gas electric coordination discussion
that we are having it's it's part of the
mix so um the important point to me when
I'm participating in the regional
activities is is um you know the other
states also will share their views and
the the the main point however is that
you know New England this is this is my
thinking New England um we have a
problem with with extreme Winters so
that's when we rely too much on gas and
gas isn't available so that can create a
situation that that would be um pretty
scary actually so so um we have to do
everything possible to solve that
problem and that may in my head I you
know I'm I don't have a preconceived
notion but if there's a need to get gas
from somewhere else through whatever
mechanisms they're talking about storage
they're talking about whether is it even
possible to build pipelines a lot of
states will tell you that's not
happening but I'm I'm just sharing my en
talks that it's part of the way I look
at
things representative Carman has a
question thank you Mr chairman and so
good to see the the puc Commissioners
here uh chairman goldner you you talked
briefly about the enforcement aspect of
what the commission does and I'm just
wondering can you elaborate on that a
bit more um what what sorts of areas you
do enforcement and and what that really
entails and maybe an example or two
thank you um so what I I meant to say
was that the enforcement uh elements uh
and audit elements in that slide went
over to the doe so there there is no
enforcement there is there is no audit
uh within the current puc so I I meant
to say that they had shifted over to the
Department of
energy representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you ch
um this is so the
Pu works a lot with making decisions
that that amount to a lot of money and
they work with some very powerful um
corporations
Industries it does the puc have an
Ethics code and if so is it enforced in
any
way touch on that so the puc is subject
to the executive Branch's ethics code uh
which is quite robust and um there is
enfor for M of it uh in instances where
complaints are made uh by uh the
Attorney General's office uh and the
ethics oversight board uh other than
that um the there are statutory
Provisions that require us to be ethical
as well I'm not going to be able to cite
it off the top of my head but it's um uh
but essentially there's a Code of
Conduct separate from the executive
branch um uh uh ethics rules that uh
we're we must follow uh and it's uh
early in in chapter 363 maybe somewhere
around section 7 I I don't have my my uh
my citation with me and uh but that it's
it's somewhere around that area um and
uh but it'll give you a sense of the
kinds of things and they're quite robust
as
well representative McGee has a question
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
being here and thank you for taking my
question um I'm looking at at uh slide
fostering retail competition they don't
have numbers on mine so I don't know 39
40 oh you can't see them okay all right
well fostering retail competition is on
the title um what I wanted to ask you
about is it looks like some of the
considerations or some of the um
attributes that you're looking at in
terms of fostering retail competition in
the energy Market include things that
are technology dependent so um time of
use rates Dynamic pricing real-time
pricing transactive energy markets um
New Hampshire is not really leveraging
any of that mostly because we're
inhibited by consistent technology that
would allow people to um to leverage
that so my question is really are are
there are there any dockets or any
conversations around where the utilities
are at in terms of uh moving the state
towards those Technologies so that we
could leverage those pieces to try and
gain efficiencies um not just in how the
market operates but also in really sort
of dialing in those values that we keep
trying to arrive at in terms of rate
making and pricing and the value of
energy that people are starting to
create on their own I know it's a big
question but I'm just curious
as far as specific dockets are concerned
I'm going to let um chairman gner talk
about it but for example data platform
that docket is ongoing and
um but I'll bring a sort of a different
perspective given my participation in
Regional activities one of the reasons
that we have a working group trying to
work on demand response there is
essentially also about what do we need
in terms of the capacity to allow retail
customers to directly participate in
Wholesale Electric markets and and that
discussion is happening the key players
are ISO in England there are other um
you know technology driven companies
that are also part of the mix there are
um companies that provide demand
response that are in the discussion so
that is that is a goal that in my
opinion is going to be not goal that is
something that we need to leverage if
you're going to be solving not merely
the the the uh the competitiveness of
markets in general but also given what's
happening in the gas market so for
winter preparedness that's going to be
an important element and that's where
they can extract value so as a
residential customer I can extract a lot
more value if I provide some sort of a
response during those times that allows
you to not rely on gas because it's not
there so it's I'm just giving you
General yes go ahead so the followup in
the conversation you and I are just
having is um it sounds like right today
uh we don't have an adequate call and
response right so if somebody if
somebody were had
capacity to respond to a demand a need
for energy at a certain time of year um
we don't have the capability to
actualize that demand response is that
correct um since we are talking in
general
terms there are uh aggregators that are
participating and so that some customers
are benefiting from it what I'm talking
about
is a more Tech technology driven
approach where even uh One retail
customer can actually participate in a
program and get
benefits thank you yeah additional
questions uh let's go with
representative
paral thank you chair V and thank you
puc for being here today um I'm looking
at page 15 your commissioner proceedings
and you've outlined uh people uh
into separate groups Department of
energy Office of Consumer Advocates and
interveners I would imagine very often
the interveners and any given case their
testimony might be significantly
different than say the department of
energy do you find that to be true of
the office of the consumer Advocate
would they do they bring a unique voice
to the table and your opinion
I think I I I I hate to start with the
answer of it depends I hate to start
with that but if I talk if I think about
the majority of
dockets um the office of the consumer
Advocate is bringing the rate payer
interests I mean so the office of the
consumer Advocate doesn't participate in
every docket partially because it
doesn't you know necessarily affect the
the rapair interests um the Department
of energy is um participates
automatically in every
docket and so you know there's a
difference in that regard and if you're
asking about the difference in what
they're bringing um the department of
energy will provide testimony in many
dockets the office of the consumer
Advocate not so much um probably a
resourcing issue or something like that
but uh the the the consumer ADV doesn't
provide testimony to the commission with
the same kind of frequency that the
department does so that's partially an
answer to your question the intervenor
input is
um you know it can be aligned with the
consumer Advocate and the department and
it can be um it can be a little bit
different but uh I
think I I don't uh I don't
see uh a huge difference in what's being
what's being brought before
us I'm sorry that was not uh so specific
but there's so many different cases
we're handling hundreds of cases it's a
little bit hard to sort of think about
the connection between all of them and I
apologize for the vagueness of the
answer no problem I that's
understandable but thank you
representative Wendy Thomas has a
question thank you Mr chair um two very
quick questions on slide 22 you you list
sewage disposal as one of your
responsibilities does that also include
the dispersement of
biosolids when you say biosolids do you
mean uh land spreading of sludge or do
you mean something else that that's
exactly what I mean uh is it's to my
knowledge we don't handle that okay um
and if I could follow up to your
previous question uh RSA 360 312 is the
statute that deals with the ethical
conduct of the Pu thank you um my second
question was um and I hate this
discussion so much however on Slide Five
you say that the doe should provide
support shouldn't that be shall Provide
support isn't that their
responsibility um that is I've got the
statutory
um the statutory provisions Down Below
in 12 P2 and 3 and 12 p33 and it it does
not say shall in the statute so we're
just reporting what the statute tells us
to do thank
you representative PL has a question uh
thank you Mr chairman um to commissioner
Chad p is
it
so yes U going back to the page um 25 I
think you mentioned you open a docket
I'll come to the question you open a
docket on uh rate payers requests for
rate change and you mentioned that this
goes back to representative Wendy
Thomas's ethics you mentioned you can't
discuss that because of
prioritary discussions my question is in
that
docket that you can
only we know there's a docket open on a
rate change we know the end result is
what is the ethical and authority of
someone to look into the docket to see
exactly what transpired in between is is
there an oversight on that thank
you can I can I ask follow of question
representative um just just so I'm clear
uh are you asking uh where can one get
information about the docket or um and
maybe see the decision that was made or
do you mean something
different internally not for the public
or myself is there an oversight within
the PO of what transpired to come up to
that end result you mean the
commissioner's deliberations
then yes we could describe as that uh I
don't think that there's oversight in
the manner that you might be
thinking uh so in other words if the
Commissioners deliberate uh you know
they'll have Frank conversations among
themselves about a docket that's before
them when reaching their decision uh but
that's um there isn't really any
oversight of that process um uh other
than the public process that this is all
part of uh so I mean everything is open
to the
public I think my question was answered
yes I was just wondering how it was done
so I can see where the Commissioners
would have okay open um private disc did
I did I answer that correct to answer
your question then uh yes chair my
question has been answered thank you
okay
good I sorry I'm new so
no I like to believe I'm new too so um I
I didn't fully understand your question
but this might be a little bit helpful
um when it's for me what's part of the
record is extremely important so we have
a process it's it's the record gets
created and that is the basis for my
ability to come to a
decision so a followup yes follow up yes
you opened that back up by that so the
Frank discussions between the
Commissioners that is not in the record
though is that true
the on the deliberations on the
deliberations
yeah if it was in the record they
couldn't have Frank discussions yeah so
I I I don't see what the issue is
there representative plog remember we're
here to ask questions not have a debate
I was trying to come to the question if
it was there and if there was someone
else in the department that had
oversight to it but now I understand it
is not there so that was answer thank
you representative Swanson has a
question thank you Mr chair thank you
Commissioners uh this is probably for uh
commissioner Chad parier did I hopefully
get that right and uh any rate uh uh
there's a lot of focus on reducing costs
and I think that we would all agree
that's you know that's usually a very
good thing but I'm also aware as a
homeowner that there are certain things
I need to plan for and invest in and
I've I gather from your discussion about
rfps versus uh I don't know direct
negotiation or something like that that
you reduce the effort and cost
associated with
RP uh Gathering uh but I I'm not seeing
in the uh emphasis on reducing rates to
uh where investment comes in and I
recall my work wife worked for PSNH ages
ago and I learned that when a uh for
example the electric company wants to
build a new power generation plant they
need to plan out for say the next 30 or
40 years that needs to last that long so
they need to figure that out and they
also need to realize they're making a
huge investment and somehow that's going
to have to be paid for uh if the it
seems like there's a goal of reducing
expenses in the current context of what
we have available where is or maybe this
is the job of somebody else or perhaps
you just leave it to the utility to
determine that hey you know we're going
to we're either going to have an
expansion of demand of electricity and
existing sources of Supply aren't going
to cover that so we're going to have to
make a major investment here uh where
where does that fit into this whole
picture I I'm glad you asked that
question because New Hampshire since the
mid90s has been deregulated meaning that
the power generation of the utilities in
New Hampshire are distribution only
utilities they don't own the generation
so that's a really important distinction
because when we talk about default
service and all these other sort
of strange terms what we're really
talking about is these utilities that
are
now that are now distribution utilities
they now have to purchase their power
from somewhere so the question is do
they purchase from a third party do they
purchase it directly from the iso New
England market and what has been going
on at the commission for the last couple
years is we've been
investigating going from the current
process or let's say the the existing
process which was to for the utilities
to purchase their power from third
parties to going directly to the
wholesale market and I'll say it this
way cutting out the middleman so um we
by looking at the data uh with the
utilities and with the doe and with the
OCA and with all the parties what we've
uh what we've determined by looking at
the data is is that yes it's true that
that middle man makes money and so the
cheapest way of getting the power is to
go directly to the wholesale market like
the Costco equivalent of power so that
you can get the lowest possible
price so sorry follow on question then
the wholesale market so you've made
several references to the wholesale
market and so is that like outs the
scope of the things that you do for rate
settings and it's some up to somebody
else to say Hey you know if I you know
I'll I'll get some land and build the
power plant and uh then I will offer to
sell for so much money to the system so
that's the wholesale Market you're
referring to and you don't get involved
in regulating that because somehow
sooner or later that you know the the
cost of building that is going to have
to be decided up front and then
somebody's maybe through the that it
becomes the wholesale cost yeah me let
me try to answer that I think of it as
like uh Hub and spokes so the iso New
England guys down in Connecticut they're
the wholesalers they're the Costco of
our space and so you can go into ISO New
England on any day at any hour at any
minute and you can purchase your power
at a wholesale price and so what the
utilities do eversource Liberty unitel
is that they have two processes for
securing their energy Supply today they
either um go directly to that wholesale
Market the iso New England market and
they purchase on a daily or even hourly
basis or they can go through that
third-party bidding process which
happens every six months and right now
the commission uh as I think
commissioner choai just to repeat what
he said earlier um today Liberty is at
50% wholesale 50% thirdparty bidding the
other two utilities are 3070 30%
wholesale 70% thirdparty bidding and
that's the mix of power that they're
purchasing from the market for their
customers um so that's that's we call
that default service which is the the
the power that's secured for you so that
you don't have to worry about it as a
homeowner I can see that I did not quite
answer your
question but I tried I I I don't want to
drag it out but I I guess I'm still not
getting the answer I thought about
what's the what's driving the wholesale
Market to invest so ISO New England has
a cue of new construction for for new uh
generation facilities that are going to
be built over the next whatever number
of years that's where that's the answer
to your question if you could look at
that cue you you could see what is o New
England thinks when you need to build or
what generators have come to is ISO New
England and offered to build and get in
that queue so that they can build
generation for the future okay thanks Mr
chair that's very good and if I if I
could add and that's a nice segue into
our next presentation from the New
England power generator Association but
I didn't mean to interrupt you Mr Del
orano thank you Mr chair uh if I could
just maybe add a little bit of Clarity
uh so before I was in government service
I represented a lot of renewable energy
developers so I can tell you how their
thinking is around some of this stuff
and this pretty much goes for any
generator not just the renewable folks
is that um all generators now are price
takers okay so they're not price makers
like they were in the past when we had a
vertically integrated utility system in
New Hampshire so that means that if you
are just say for instance a solar
developer and uh you want to
interconnect uh you know a megawatt of
solar here in New Hampshire uh onto the
grid someplace you need to model your
economics around what the wholesale
price is what what price you there
actually going to get for that power but
solar like some other Renewables they
have other adders to them so you've got
RPS um you have uh tax credits one of
the things that I did in private
practice was I monetized tax credits for
folks so that uh they could develop some
of these uh solar
projects
and once you kind of have a handle on
those things I'm trying to keep this
very general uh then a developer can
make a economic decision to see whether
or not they're going to be able to make
their required rate of return these
things have nothing to do with what uh
we regulate on on the Utility side the
Investments we regulate are to the
distribution system not on the
generation side so really free market
participants uh developers are the folks
that uh decide whether or not their
economic model is going to work for them
and uh they'll attract investment for it
as well as uh uh debt financing uh and
again monetizing those uh federal tax
credits are also very important but uh
at the end of the day being a price
taker they have to model their economics
around what the market is likely to pay
for their power and so it's a risky
business it's not as uh it's not a um a
sure thing uh you know prog some
programs look to try and uh uh you know
normalize that a bit but uh it's not a
uh it's it's not like how it was when uh
Public Service would decide to build a
power plant uh and they would forecast
out demand for a number of years and
they would build a facility in order to
meet that demand it's somewhat different
does did that answer your
question okay great I think we need to
uh segue into our next presentation from
the New
England what's
that all right one last question and
then we'll move on to the New England
power generators Association thank you
and I look forward to that presentation
um just a very quick question on on
slide 14 the last bullet is that the
commission can order reparations or
impose penalties can you give us some
examples of reparations or penalties and
the last time one was imposed thank
[Music]
you you want me okay uh so I'm GNA
answer your your second part of your
question first uh again I'm I'm new to
the commission so I couldn't tell you
when the last time the commission had uh
imposed a penalty or reparations
generally what this is around is
consumer complaints so if a consumer
complains about a you know being charged
uh more than what they were supposed to
be charged uh that complaint would first
originate over at the department of
energy the department of energy would
investigate the complaint uh and would
generally be resolved at that level
however let's imagine a situation where
a rape payer was uh still dissatisfied
that rape payer could then um it's not
quite appeal but they could then
petition the Pu to look into that matter
and the Pu could hold a hearing and try
to judge the facts of it to see whether
or not the utility had actually acted
wrongly in that case um if we find that
they did then uh we could impose a
penalty and by reparations that means uh
if someone paid uh you know 9 cents
instead of 5 cents then uh we could give
them the Delta of 4 cents as part of
that order that that's mainly what
that's uh around there are some other
more nuanced areas but um they don't
arise frequently uh and uh I I don't
know have you guys ever rewarded
reparations to anybody no so this is
something that hasn't come up I think in
a little
while again I cannot give you a specific
docket but I'm going back to my
experience so this is before I became a
commissioner I do remember there were
times when a utility was penalized so
I'm just giving a general context so you
know
that's did happen to the best of my
recollection okay I want to thank all
three of you again for being here a
outstanding
presentation excellent answers to our
questions we really appreciate you
providing that resource to us thank you
again all right next up the New England
power generators Association
good afternoon Molly and Dan I'll let
you introduce
yourselves but uh want to welcome you to
stn and we're happy to be here while
while everyone gets settled Dan our um
president is um handing out our
presentation um in the interest of time
we thought we would keep this more
conversational um and so we will refer
to this but we're not going through the
slides if you would rather we want to
give you a brief orientation as to who
we are um and and what we do and how we
got here and what the grid looks like
now and going forward and really reserve
the majority of the time for question
and answer as I know that that's really
where where the committee wanted to
spend its time so once so I'll give
people a moment to make sure they have
their
presentation Jump Right In all right
good afternoon thank you for your time
I'm Molly Connors I'm an analyst with
the New England power generators
Association this is Dan Dolan my boss
our president um so we I I think we'll
be able to clarify any questions
regarding wholesale markets and the way
power plants are developed I was here
for the Pu and know that there were some
questions around that hopefully between
us today and ISO New England tomorrow
you'll be able to get some clarity on
those issues on how on how the wholesale
markets work and and how they developed
so first off um who are we um in in your
presentation this would be slide two
this is really our cover slide who are
we um the we represent the the power
generating facilities the power plants
in New England that are not owned by
utilities and so that's the vast
majority of power plants in New England
they are not own owned by vertically
integrated utilities and so our Members
Own and operate about 27,000 megawatt of
generating capacity that's the vast
majority well over 95% % of the
generating capacity in New England um of
that we have just about every type of
technology in our membership we have
coal plant we have oil gas we have
nuclear lots of solar offshore wind um
onshore wind really every type of
technology is probably a member of our
of our of our organization um of the
27,000 megawatts though about 30% are
non-emitting or renewable that could be
nuclear that could be a different type
of um of Ren resource again it sort of
underscores the diversity of the
generating facilities in New
England um collectively about you know
about 4,000 people are employed by the
generating facilities throughout New
England specific to New Hampshire our
members um provide about
4,300 megawatts of generating capacity
um and really there is a a a large
amount of diversity within that too we
have a nuclear power plant there are
biomass facilities um run a river Hydro
facilities solar facilities again
there's a lot of diversity within the
membership um and within within New
Hampshire about 1800 megawatts are
carbon free or zero carbon and about 750
to a th000 people are employed at the
power plants in New England so that's
the oh um do we want questions or should
I
keep okay the my question is it says um
you provide approximately 4,300
megawatts of capacity for New Hampshire
and I was just wondering if you knew
what the overall
capacity number is for the State of New
Hampshire in other words like what
percentage um so I would say um when we
think about power generating in the
megawatts um there our members NEPA
represents by and large the larger power
plants now certainly there are smaller
um smaller power plants in particular
I'm thinking of hydro facilities the
larger Hydro facilities are members of
NEPA um I would say usually one or five
megawatts or greater but throughout New
Hampshire and really New England there
are a lot of smaller hydros those are
not necessarily NEPA members same for
solar if there's a solar facility that's
commercial scale large it's largely a
NEPA member but the smaller ones like
rooftop solar those typically are not
members of our
organization okay I think what I was
trying to get at was of if 4,300
megawatts is uh what percentage of do do
you have an idea of how many megawatts
we need in order to supply our electric
needs currently um that's a good
question I think um so I would say our
Members Plus the smaller ones that I
mentioned are the total amount I don't
know I think that might be a good
question for ISO New England or can take
a crack so representative good to see
you um uh it's a comparable percentage
to what it is region wide so we are in
the upper 90% of overall capacity it is
notable however that New Hampshire is a
net exporter of electricity as well and
so if the specific Quest is what
percentage of our members provide the
needs of New Hampshire I don't have
those numbers to to my fingertips
because it gets a little tricky what's
in State versus sold into the the
regional
market thank you um so moving on to the
to the next slide I want to get a little
bit into something I think the committee
has already discussed a little bit which
is how did we get where we are why are
the merchant power plants not owned by
utilities and I think the previous
speakers got to this a little little bit
you know for from the time electricity
was invented um your utility owned
everything it owned the power plant it
owned the big transmission line it owned
the distribution the smaller line You
could argue they even owned the
customers because customers had no
choice um over time particularly in New
England in the 90s there were increasing
frustrations with consumers with
legislators with Regulators that the
cost overruns at utilities were
unmanageable um largely focused on
construction and operation of power
plants really We Were Striking a point
where regulation was just insufficient
to get at the challenges a lot of cost
overruns with power plants and then the
inefficient operations of them and so
what what happened was a lot of
legislators decided to break up the
Monopoly in terms of the power
generating facilities and so what they
did was Al allow the power plants to be
sold off from the utilities and private
companies that Focus exclusively on
operating and constructing and
maintaining power plants took over that
specific part of the energy system and
so that's why now you have these energy
companies that Focus almost exclusively
on on running and operating power plants
as in comparison with the utility that's
really focusing on wires and poles and
delivering electricity and so we we have
seen a number of improvements as a
result of this first off the overall
efficiency at most plants increased by
20% just by spinning them off from the
utilities and focusing them uh forcing
them to be um subject to competitive
forces that's almost like if you you
know if you needed five plants under
utility ownership to meet a certain need
under competition you needed only four
it's a significant Market Improvement
and Dan will talk more about what that's
meant in terms of cost and in terms of
environmental impact but overall it's
been very very positive um and I would
just um end my portion of the sort of
how did we get here by saying you know
after restructuring after the power
plants were sold off we have still seen
significant investment in New England in
terms of power plants billions of
dollars have been invested more than
10,000 megawatts of power generating
facilities have been constructed
throughout New England in response to
competitive forces and that has all been
without rate payer risk this has not
been part of the rate base in the
utilities this has been outside of
economic regulation this has been
through competitive forces administered
in a market run by ISO New
England can we interrupt you for a
question here of course you're the chair
representative Vice chair Thomas thank
you Mr chairman uh thank you for taking
my question since you open the door uh
my of your last statement I will say
therefore do you see a open opportunity
in investment for small scale nuclear to
come in into the state and would you
support that you know that's a very good
question some of our members are do own
nuclear facilities right now what we're
hearing is um and I'm sure Dan will at
on this but small modular nuclear
reactors are extremely expensive and the
wholesale electricity markets have
driven cost down overall that has
benefited consumers um I know that this
is a technology that's of great interest
to a lot of people right now what we
hear from our members who do invest in
power plants is a challenge is the
capital intensity the cost of building a
new nuclear power facility even a small
modular reactor can be quite
inhibitive and if if I could pile on to
that I think part of the the mix and the
challenge that that we Face here is uh
resources that are high Capital cost
upfront cost that then have low marginal
cost in terms of the energy they produce
to uh to come into place think nuclear
think things like wind some some other
resources like that versus relatively
lower upfront Capital cost but then a
higher marginal cost to operate and
again here an example is something like
a natural gas power plant where it's
relatively cheaper to build but then has
a higher fuel cost to operate into the
market to that tension that exists in in
every electricity Market in in the world
with respect to small modular reactors
in general I am long-term quite bullish
but we need to build one somewhere first
and that right now is the biggest
challenge is there are pilot projects
and initial projects in places like
Ontario
Wyoming let's see how some of those
initial developments work and then I
think the site of large scale existing
nuclear facilities like seabook are
prime opportunities to potentially add
on to look something like a small
modular reactor but right now we see it
as something that is unlikely to to
happen in a place like New England until
we see a demonstration uh
elsewhere representative
Kaplan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for coming in to take our question
questions today um in a similar vein I'm
wondering if you're if from a
generator's perspective would do you see
uh the prospect for renewable utility
scale generation you know uh we talked
this morning about the renewable
portfolio standard and you know where
that's going to go uh you know just
based on Market forces going out 10 20
years what what is the outlook for
utility scale renewable including
offshore
wind uh so we we see a a tremendous
amount of development of renew that's
been the fastest growing segment of the
New England fuel mix overall if you skip
over to to slide seven here you'll see
that Renewables now make up just under
20% of the actual generation uh the
megawatt hours produced in in New
England a lot of that is some of the um
the older Legacy Hydro uh facilities a
number of which are on the Connecticut
River here in in New Hampshire but we
also see that from growing segments of
utility scale large scale wind solar uh
we do represent um the first commercial
scale offshore Wind Facility Vineyard
offshore uh off the coast of of
Massachusetts and we continue to see
opportunities for for Renewables r large
um if if I could bounce around a little
bit here because I think this is going
to touch on some of this if you then
skip over to to slides nine and 10 here
that I'm going to try and take
collectively I think fundamentally uh
the the issue that that we have whether
that's with respect to um uh the I think
the the question earlier from
representative Swanson to the the Pu
commissioner some of the questions here
with new nuclear and and Renewables
is what is the the actual Supply mix
that we're going to need uh not today
but tomorrow uh what are the the price
signals that are going to help get us
there and to what degree is investment
going to support that and how does that
fundamentally get at the most important
element of these markets which is reli
ility and so what we see today is a
major point of transition in in the
electricity market and we've seeing
these come almost once every 10 years or
so feels like it's the rhythm of this uh
where right now we see significant
amounts of older generation uh either
retiring or making announcements for for
permanent retirement what you see on
slide nine is uh a number of those
facilities that uh between the years
2024 and 2028 we expect roughly 3,000
megawatt of existing facilities to go
away in place of that there has been a
tremendous push particularly from some
of the Southern New England states to
then uh uh determine what types of
resources they want to see come in and
and replace that almost entirely uh
renewable uh facilities and so they've
entered into decades long contract to
support some of those those facilities
and here we see large scale growth on so
solar offshore wind and Contracting for
Canadian Hydro over new transmission
line this that those numbers should
roughly over the next four or five years
balance out with about 3,000 megawatts
going away about 3,000 megawatts
entering the market and again this has
been the rhythm of this market for about
30 years now the challenge that is
unique to today and I think moving
forward uh and and I I would be most
interested in having the conversation
with this committee is that system has
worked um very smoothly in large part
because over those last 20 to 30 years
electricity demand has regularly gone
down and so there has been much more
bandwidth to match some of that exit and
entry in the marketplace with a little
bit more wiggle room what we are now
facing is the first period of time in a
long long time in which demand is going
up now it's going up slowly right now
now but the expectation is that that
increase could certainly accelerate and
certainly I think we have a
responsibility to examine what happens
if it does accelerate and that now
collapses that wiggle room that
bandwidth and the the challenge Now is
really making sure that as we get those
entry and exit signals that they are
lining up and that there is not a lag
time uh between those that we continue
to maintain the high degree of
reliability that we've been able to uh
enjoy and serve in this region um
particularly as we further Electrify
broader segments of the economy and it
becomes a more important societal issue
to maintain that reliability
overall follow up yeah so that thank you
for taking my question uh Mr chair so
that you know brings up the obvious
question what are the bottlenecks to
making sure that
happens the the two most fundamental are
sighting and financing and uh right now
uh the the sighting is um predominantly
in the control of the individual states
and we are seeing movement uh in across
a number of New England states to try
and um either streamline or at least
facilitate a more timely consideration
of large scale Projects New Hampshire
went through a major uh reform of of its
citing statute several years ago and I
know um much more recently that has
become uh uh reemerged as a topic of
Interest we would be very interested in
in having that conversation with you all
uh there was a major piece of
legislation signed into law in
Massachusetts just uh about six weeks
ago um that uh I think is a major step
forward there and my hope is that we see
that translated in in other states uh
the the I think the most fundamental
challenge that we have in New Hampshire
and unique to New England is uh this
tension between local control and
Statewide societal needs um the the uh
the the government structure of town
meeting is a remarkable and I think
unique aspect to New England governance
it makes it hard to build
multi-community large scale
infrastructure projects whether that's
energy or anything else um and so part
of the tension that that we have is how
do we maintain local control and
recognition of the the challenges and
the benefits that can acur to a host
Community while still making sure that
we're creating an environment in which
these large manufacturing industrial
facilities can get built and cited that
serve a much wider population base I
don't have a silver bullet answer but
that's a tension that that we Face the
second is that financing piece is uh how
do we pay for it and right now uh New
England wide and and commissioner jatai
um uh spoke a little bit to this we are
in the midst of a multi-year effort to
do the most fundamental redesign of our
wholesale electricity markets to more
sharply account and accredit for what
individual resources are actually
providing for reliability and paying
them for it and those that are not
shouldn't it's been a long time coming
and we're getting there um and our hope
is that over the next 18 to 24 months we
have a much more granular and sharply
focused Market design that can help uh
get that financing done so that we can
build uh uh those new resources coming
in but the way that the electricity
Market is designed is for the most
economical resource to be built and um
and right now that does not account for
certain uh environmental or climate
attributes and to the degree an
individual State wants those uh that's
where we also see now attention of
States um adding additional funding or
subsidies for individual resources
because they're not being called for
through the market
itself representative Corman thank you
Mr chairman thank you both for coming uh
you actually spurred my thought about
two questions so uh I'm wondering about
the interconnection cue and what sort of
obstacle that poses for the G generators
but also just as I look through here I
didn't see anything about
storage and uh of course Schiller and
marac station are are going to become
predominantly storage Sher entirely
marac combines solar and storage and
also I'm thinking about the form energy
project up in Maine which is going to be
a huge amount of storage and I know
technically that's not generation but it
is putting stuff onto the grid and uh
I'm I'm wondering how that fits into
what you folks do
sure so I'll take the second one first
on on the storage side I I actually
don't look it look at it as as
incremental I look at it as moving uh
generation from one period of time to
another um some have have turned it a
time machine in that respect and it can
create efficiencies on the system in
which there are periods of time in which
we have excess generation and move them
that that generation to then a period of
time of higher demand so there is a
tremendous value of of storage overall
um the the fundamental um issue that we
have uh with storage is that that
overall duration um where I think right
now the the fastest growing segment of
storage are 2 to 4our length batteries
that are um tremendously valuable of Mo
moving power within a day I I think of
them as kind of an
intraday help uh of taking from certain
portions of the day and pushing it to
others the the the most simple way in my
mind is take it from you know 2 o'clock
in the afternoon when uh the sun is
shining bright brightest move it to 7 or
8 o'clock at night as as we see that
evening ramp up and the Sun is going
down um I think fundamentally from a
reliability standpoint the biggest
challenge in New England going forward
are going to be those multi-day cold
snaps particularly as we bring in more
heat pumps higher electricity loads in
the winter months uh in which we um uh
see some of this the constraints on the
fuel delivery system
overall H how do we deal with day five
six or seven of a 10-day cold snap in
which there's six inches of snow on on
top of a lot of the solar panels and it
just is one of those still wind days um
that that's really cold that is where
multi-day storage systems could be Tre
tremendously um beneficial the the form
energy project uh up in Lincoln Maine is
a proposal for a 100h hour battery um
that obviously um is is very exciting
and and creates some real opportunity I
will say like small modular reactors we
haven't seen one yet and so it's it's
hard to really say um exactly what that
impact is going to be or to what degree
that is scalable or replicable um
overall but yes that is um a a really
important um piece
on the interconnection side that is a
very difficult issue I will say we have
seen improvements um at ISO New England
um uh particularly with respect to
clustering and being able to model
multiple projects at once and not just
go project by project that being said
this is always going to be a frustrating
period in which there are bottlenecks on
mapping that system overall um which is
where we have frankly um pushed more on
um uh on making sure that state citing
statutes um uh can be done as quickly as
possible so that when a project does get
through that that interconnection uh
study at ISO New England we're ready to
move and and move forward so I know
that's not an entirely satisfying answer
on on the interconnection side but it
it's a tricky
issue representative Matson has a
question I was just wondering do you
know how many megawatt hour of storage
we have right now in New Hampshire I
don't
well so we we focus a lot on lithian ion
batteries they're the newer technology
and I think you see a lot of that on the
distribution system but historically
we've actually already had a lot of
storage facilities on the grid in the
terms of um um Hydro pumped hydro store
power so there are two large facilities
one in western Mass and one in
Conneticut both M they're both in
Massachusetts I've only been to one and
they are one is about what 8,000
megawatts and the other is 10 or am I
one is three oh I'm way off yeah I need
to drop a zero anyway they're probably a
combination of 2 or 3,000 megawatts and
they're at the top of a mountain um on a
river and so they can pump water to the
top of the mountain and hold it in a
pond and when the when the grid needs
electricity um the water goes down the
mountain and Spins the turbine in the
other way and so historically we've
actually had a lot of storage I think
the question is what about the batteries
that are made out of lithian I you know
I think we're seeing a lot of investment
on the distribution system I think um in
terms of resilience and supporting
communities maybe after a storm is where
you see a lot of investment in that I
think in this in terms of the wholesale
electricity markets where you have
larger larger resources um you um you
see I think a a good chunk of the iso
New England Q is battery storage I but I
I think it would be in the thousands but
those are what's being proposed in terms
of what's actually on the grid it's
probably in the hundreds
representative
bernardy thank you Mr chairman turning
to slide five you have 800% increase in
transmission rates since 2004 what's the
Big Driver of that and what can we do to
knock that down a
bit this is our favorite slide and the
one that gets the most attention um and
and and truly it it is put here not as
uh an advocate for a specific policy or
a direct answer because it is a really
complicated answer right our job is to
produce electrons that that then we
require transmission to move to to the
market to get to our customer base uh
and uh New England unsurprisingly has an
old transmission and distribution
Network and it does need to be
reinvested in and and kept up this is
largely put on this slide because we
also know that one of the biggest
pressures you all feel as the
representatives of your constituents is
what's going on in my electric bill why
is the price what it is and to recognize
that the production of electricity like
on the prior slide is a volatile
commodity and we see that go up and down
uh year to year and it tends to be the
sharpest mover uh we also don't want to
ignore the Frog getting boiled in the
pot of water slowly over time with
increasing temperatures and that's
really what we're seeing on on the
transmission side I will say from a
policy standpoint it I believe
personally it is the result of of two um
uh well-intentioned policies that had
unintended consequences the first is
that in 2005 Congress passed the uh
energy Policy Act of 2005 that created
an explicit um uh increased Revenue uh
opportunity for largescale transmission
development by utilities it is the
national policy of the United States to
build more transmission to farther and
farther flung places largely to
interconnect both populations but with
um uh sources that produce lots of wind
lots of solar and even um uh uh the gas
fields building a gas plant right on top
of the gas fields and then moving that
gas by wire uh through electricity so
one is uh uh guaranteed High rates of
return for building that transmiss
Mission and like any rational economic
actor you're you're going to put that
money in in in place there the second is
we've gotten the utilities out of the
business of owning and operating power
plants and so the only place for them to
make money is on improvements to the
transmission and distribution system
overall and again that's their job they
should do that um but overall it is
creating an economic incentive to
further focus in those areas which is
why New England pays the highest rate of
Wholesale Transmission of any Market in
the United
States okay is there anything else you
would like to tell us about your
presentation so the only other one and I
know chairman in particular this has
been an interest of uh of yours coming
into this this session in particular um
but do want to highlight slide 11 here
um with respect to to Electric
reliability uh as I said earlier uh
Electric reliability is clearly our our
top priority um however it is not the
only one and uh the other overused uh
phrase that that we have is in this
industry is that it's a three-legged
stool we have affordability we have
reliability and we have trying to do it
increasingly clean and uh the the trick
is I can
largely provide you policy answers for
getting two out of three of those
getting all three at once is really
really hard and right now what we are
seeing is as electricity demand
continues to increase as we see some of
the older facilities that either need
reinvestment or just have reached the
end of their useful life go away how do
we make sure that that reliability stool
is maintained and that has become under
um uh even more attention and and
tension and pressure as we see not only
electrification happen at the retail
level between individual homeowners in
investing in their heating systems in
their vehicles but really what we're
seeing is in other parts of the country
right now uh extraordinary growth in
manufacturing onshoring of manufacturing
and uh use of AI data centers
particularly as we look at the
Mid-Atlantic and Midwest extraordinary
electricity demand that has not yet
happened in New England but I emphasize
yet and so what what we are um trying to
highlight is that uh we are watching
this we uh uh certainly are
extraordinarily aware of the situation
uh the the the map we have here and and
recognize it's kind of small here I
think sometimes we have a tendency and
understandably parochially to really
only be worried about our sandbox to
think that that New England's on on a
knife edge and really um if you look at
across the country we're in really good
company
uh this is a national issue uh this is
something that uh is the top priority
right now as we look at a changing
Federal Energy Regulatory Commission
with a a new Administration coming into
place at the North American Electric
reliability corporation which is the
entity designated um for electric
reliability uh there was also uh a
report um where kind of the executive
summary was just issued uh about 10 days
ago the full report is expected next
week There's an organization called the
Northeast um uh p uh uh Power
coordinating Council npcc sorry we have
too many acronyms uh they are the
regional entity designated by nerk to
worry about our corner of the world all
of them are highlighting um that uh
reliability is concerned long term
however I also want to stress that uh
we're not in the red right this is an
important serious issue we today do not
see um an outright emergency here but we
need to be mindful we need to Be
watchful and and certainly that is
something that as uh we engage with you
all for the rest of this session is
going to be front of Mind as as we look
at at the very Pol various policies and
proposals that get brought
forward well thank you very much I uh I
have one comment and then one question
for you the comment relates to something
you talked about earlier small modular
nuclear power at the end of November the
nuclear regulatory nuclear Regulatory
Commission granted permission to Kos
power to build two 35 megawatt bolt and
salt react reactors in Texas and uh I
believe that once this small modular
nuclear reactor industry gets moving
it's going to take off very very quickly
and I think that process has begun my
question
though uh relates
to since you do a lot of your work in
Massachusetts you also mentioned earlier
that Massachusetts six weeks ago passed
into new energy
law the Massachusetts fiscal
Alliance pointed out that that law
contains a requirement that the
utilities in Massachusetts purchase 1500
megaw of storage by July 1st of
2025 and at $500,000 a megawatt that
works out to $750
million that Massachusetts utilities are
going to have to spend between now and
July 1st of 2025 is that even
possible I don't
know how can this possibly be a good
idea I just what were they thinking I
don't I don't know any uh further
questions representative
partial thank you chair it's good to see
you both thank you for coming um my
question is also about batteries and we
tend to look at a large scale um
megawatt range of what we need to
produce when it comes to batteries um is
there have there been develops upon
micro I I hasate the word micr GD but
smaller batteries such as you already
have that would meet your two to four
hour demand for being able to time shift
and could you speak to that a bit sure
and that is where we've seen the the
large scale growth and in fact I think
just about every one of our um uh
members is looking to or has already put
batteries behind the fence line at their
power plant itself to optimize the the
fuel use and take advantage of when they
have opportunities to produce
electricity at a lower cost store it and
then put it on to the the the Grid in in
moments in which either they are
constrained from a fuel perspective uh
an air permit um perspective or in which
it's just cheaper to to discharge that
battery so absolutely there there's a
huge role for those shorter duration
batteries I I just wanted to to temper
um uh some of the the potential
expectations of how much are we going to
be able to to lean on that to to Really
solve our our issues overall the other
area that um I I think is um to come in
in New England is to what degree we see
uh distributed batteries in the home or
in the business aggregated at scale and
then be able to participate as was
mentioned um by the the Pu Commissioners
either from a demand response
perspective or the the other kind of
topic dour these days is what are called
virtual power plants which are this
aggregated Demand aggregated Storage
that that then is is scalable there
there have been pilot projects including
here in New Hampshire um doing that I I
think that's uh an exciting interesting
um place to to further develop and is
also this marriage between the retail
regulatory side that the Pu over
oversees with that distribution and
homeowner um participation and the whole
sale
Market okay I want to thank you both
both for being here excellent
presentation very informative and uh a
good discussion as
well so that concludes our presentation
portion of today's activity we are now
going to resume some of the orientation
activity that we didn't get to earlier
today this morning when we started our
orientation we talked about General um
committee organizational issues but I
think I think
it's important to talk about the two
activities in which we primarily engage
one is public hearing of bills and two
is executive sessions of bills so I'm
going to turn the um discussion over to
my vice chair representative Thomas to
discuss public hearings how we do them
and what's important in a public hearing
and then after he's done representative
Bernardi is going to talk about
executive sessions how we conduct those
and what's important to know about those
so representative Thomas thank you Mr
chairman uh first I'd like to say
that every committee will run
differently based on the Chairman's
personality and way that he would like
to run a meeting so what what we may do
here may be a little bit different than
what you may see or experience in in
other committees but there are certain
basic guidelines that every committee
will follow and that's what that's kind
of what we'll You Know cover here um I
guess the Golden Rule with any public
hearing and this is really for the
benefit of the of of our new members but
as a reminder to our returning members
that uh there may be times when a
particular issue um is very passionate
to you and you may may or may not want
to bring out certain points during
testimony of public hearing uh
our our uh way of doing things is to ask
questions that will bring out the facts
or the clarity of what is being
discussed as it pertains to the bill in
question and so we don't engage in any
debate with the testifier um sometimes
there may be a tendency to a to you ask
one question they have a response and
all of a sudden you feel like asking a
second one and all of a sudden you're
going back and forth well the chair will
regulate that but I would I I would say
that make sure your questions are
phrased so that you get the information
that you want and not subject to two or
three follow-ups uh with only one word
answers so we want to make sure that
those questions
uh just speak to the bill itself not to
the ideology in general but to what that
bill is supposed to be doing so if you
can keep that in mind and in conjunction
with that when you do ask a question we
want you to ask a question we don't want
a 15 20 second 30 second 40 second uh
dissertation speech on your feelings on
the bill um and then uh have to be
reminded where where is the question so
please when you raise your hand be ready
to ask the question and hopefully
hopefully hopefully it never begins with
would you
believe um so uh those are some of the
things that I'd like to point out uh to
keep the testimonies rolling and um keep
them of course always always being
respect to the testifier no matter what
they're saying uh or no matter what the
issue is and just please form your
questions to either bring out something
that you feel will clarify to you or to
the committee uh what the testfire is
actually getting
to uh so I covered think the thing about
speeches no speeches oh yes um questions
first of all I'll say this rather
bluntly nobody speaks until they're
recognized by the chair and you get
recognized by The Chair by raising your
hand and in some
cases you're waving like this so that
the chair can see you past
me I'm
kidding yes some some some of us are
being blocked by people straight up yeah
straight up you know or or e or so
because sometimes like this uh he's not
going to see it so
anyway yes this is a question on that
okay thank you for thank you for the
question by the way um when I see people
over here trying to get your attention
do you mind if I just raise my hand even
if I don't have a question that's to
call it I I don't want to be imposing
her I don't I I don't have a problem
with that sometimes I will raise my hand
for the chair because he hasn't seen the
person over there but but but you know
that's obviously you know okay thank you
and then then you can say no it's not me
is
her so um but yeah it's a good point cuz
we do have it's kind of limited seing
here it is hard to see visibility is
restricted along this table yes I didn't
see Lex earlier this morning because he
was hidden behind everybody else between
me and him so so um so uh you going on
and um oh by the way um uh if you think
you'll have a followon question please
ask permission again from the chair for
a follow on instead of just blurting it
out that helps too um when the sponsor
is a member of the committee uh from
what we are being told this year I know
it might have been different before in
the past but if you are a sponsor or if
your name is a on the bill as a
co-sponsor you may and you are in this
committee and it's your bill you're a
co-sponsor of of that bill then you may
get up and you may testify
on that bill but then you are to return
here and you are not to ask any more
questions uh on any of the other
testifiers that that that come
up and that yes the hand is raised so so
just to make sure that we're clear on
this suppose I'm a co-sponsor on a bill
and I do not testify then I may ask
questions no
to that question is yes you can ask
questions if you do not testify but if
you testify you return to your seat and
then you can't ask questions very good
thank you yeah so just
testify
um
yes thank you if you are slated to
testify May you ask questions before you
testify or is it a if you are going to
testify or did testify you you don't get
to ask questions if I have a pink card
with your name on it then I won't let
you ask a
question okay so it's yes if you're
going to testify then you are not a
questioner cor and if you don't have a
pink card you don't testify so you might
want to explain pink cards for our new
members yeah well since that that
subject came up everybody who comes in
here who wants to testify even if they
want to say I support the bill and
that's all they say um should fill out a
pink card it'll be your name and where
you're from yeah right there that's it's
a good example be where from who who you
representing and what your and do you
support the bill yes no or neutral
whatever um please do it up front early
because um the chair uh will take the
pink cards before the testifying begins
and he will arrange them and he will
also figure out how many we have and how
many minutes he may have to allow for
the the testifying if um if we only get
two or three um uh pink sheets or pink
cards up front and then with you know at
the very very end all of a sudden we get
six more pink cards why that might
affect the timing of of the testifier
and the amount of time that people may
have time to actually testify so please
put your pink card card in first and if
you if you think you might but you're
not sure you might want to put your pink
card in anyway and then you always wave
off and say I've decided not to testify
and that would save us some time as well
I would think yes representative Thomas
thank you um the signin sheets so if I'm
a co-sponsor for Bill and I sign in on
the sheet not the pin card I can still
ask questions as long as I don't testify
correct correct thank you and okay any
um and since you brought that up uh for
the benefit of the new members uh we
have on the shelves here when we have
testifying we have what they're called
the Blue sheet and that's in every
committee and if you see a bill that you
say I'd like to say yay or nay on uh you
certainly can just sign your name and
say I support or I I don't support
that's called the Blue sheet and you can
I would uh recommend that if you see any
bill that you figure feel that you need
to voice your opinion on that just put
your name down on that blue sheet it
does not commit you to testify in that
cas committee it just says that you are
for or against a certain Bill and that's
what that's what we mean when we say
blue sheet yes represent n thank you we
might want to mention that um anyone can
look at the blue sheet but we are no
longer required to read the names out
loud of who signed in on the blue
sheet true sometimes we get 20 or 30
names on there it takes a long
time yes represent thank thank you uh
also in addition to the blue sheet
people can sign in online I don't know
if you were going to mention that but I
figured it's Germaine so people can sign
in online as supporting opposing or
being neutral and also submit testimony
online do we yes go ahead representative
not thank you do we still get a count
I'm looking at you representative po um
will we still be getting a count in
terms of for and against because
sometimes it's helpful also to know if
the public is weighing in on a bill of
ours I I asked that question during our
training session and I was told that is
no longer required to report on the
numbers of of the blue sheet although
the blue sheet will go into the record
as such and can be easily looked
at where's the record well it would be
in the um uh in the in the office over
here okay
um what you mean by that you're talking
about the
uh
session yeah good talk about that yeah
and this is
new yeah there's there's yeah there's
something new that has come up in terms
of um conflict of interest and Rec uh
recusal and I think the chairman
May so last last session we passed a
house well we passed a bill was signed
in law into law by the governor that
spells out some specific situations and
Rule changes with regards to conflicts
of interest and
recusal and so if you for example like I
know representative reels used to work
for revision revision energy he he no
longer works there but if you were still
working there and we had a solar bill
under the new um legislation that was
passed last year you would have to
recuse yourself from voting on that bill
uh you could still ask questions about
it in a in a
hearing but um you would have to preface
your questions by saying that um I
recuse myself from voting on this bill
um that probably isn't going to happen
very often but it may happen
occasionally so just U be thinking in
the back of your mind whether or not
there might ever be any conflict of
interest between something that you're
involved with I know some of you are
still employed have businesses
representative Summers
representative schneller Etc uh be
thinking in the back of your mind
whether or not there would ever be a
conflict of interest between
your business interests and bills that
we're hearing before our
committee and and if that occurs
hopefully it happens before we have
executive session so you can inform the
chairman so that he knows um I'd like to
State one more thing too it go it goes
into the decorum during public hearing
and and that
is and again for the benefit of our new
members we sit here and we listen to the
testifiers and the testifiers can many
times can be very passionate and they
may say things that you are really in
favor of and it's so much so you might
say yeah well uh we should here as a
committee we should remain um
respectfully silent while they're
testifying except when you're asking a
question and uh although this has only
happened on a couple of occasions um we
are not expected nor will we condone any
verbal or visual reaction from the
committee members after a testimony is
complete I know there was one time when
it was a very was a very wellone uh
testimony although we may not have
agreed with some of what this person was
saying but some did and they started to
clap we we do not Clap the general
public may attempt to Clack and
hopefully the chair will gav them to say
order in in the room but we we do not do
engage any of that here we just uh
whoever is talking might just thank the
person and we just kind of move on so
just a kind of a reminder because there
will be some passionate issues that come
here from from uh time to time and um
especially when the room is filled with
people so just a kind of a point there
anything else Mr chairman can you think
of so just to reinforce what Vice chair
Thomas has been talking about our goal
in a public hearing is to get the facts
so that we can have the information we
we need individually and collectively to
make a decision about what to do with
this
bill our questions should focus on the
bill itself as much as
possible and not be reflective
necessarily of our own personal feelings
we're here to gather
information as representative Bernardi
will explain in just a moment we can
talk about our opinions and our
attitudes toward ail in executive
session but during a public hearing all
we're here to do is to gather
information ask intelligent questions so
that we can extract information that we
can use to make good
decisions and with that I'm going to
turn it over to representative Bernardi
to talk
about representative Corman thank you uh
are you planning to schedule hearings in
half hour slots like last question
yes representative Bernardi will now
explain what happens in an executive
session thank you Mr chair so starting
off preliminary requirements uh
executive uh sessions obviously have to
be scheduled and this and the chair is
looking at uh the total number of bills
that we have to uh get through and and
the uh calendar deadlines for them uh
whether they have Financial notes or not
uh a executive session requires a
quorum uh and if you don't have a quorum
you can't move forward at all as opposed
to a hearing where that is not
necessarily necessary
um hence there is a opportunity for
Replacements uh uh that be made by
seeking uh uh Replacements from the
majority or minority offices that has to
be done the close of on the before the
close of business on the day before the
Committee
hearing so the uh executive session
starts with the chairman opening the
session that's yes can I interrupt just
a second the day before the executive
session not before the hearing oh did I
say that okay you said he the day before
the executive session
yes yes just to clarify so the day
before the executive session what has to
be done the the scheduling has to be
done or or seeking substitutes I wasn't
substitute has to be sought from that
from the respective
office it used to be 3:00 as and and now
they this guidance says the day before
so I don't know when the cut off is you
might check in with your respective
offices
okay uh so the uh the session is opened
with uh by the chair no motion required
but then then we can move into a
discussion or a friendly debate or
whatever kind of uh facilitated uh uh
discussion that we may want to entertain
that is between the committee members in
doing that if the chair
recognizes uh that we need to ask a
question of someone who may be expert
and in the uh audience or available that
that question can be uh made to the
public at the chair's
discretion once that discussion is over
even and there may not be any we may
move right straight to uh um a motion uh
if no discussion is is required the
motion has to be
seconded uh and the motion may be
withdrawn as well if if uh if things uh
don't move as
anticipated replacement members are not
allowed to make the motion or second the
motion the eligible motions are ought to
pass or ought to pass with amendment
inexpedient to legislate retain if it's
in the first year of the bium and refer
to interim study if it's in the second
year a subcommittee chair may be uh
recognized to make the motion if the
bill came from a
subcommittee uh and that preliminary
discussion on the bill is appropriate o
if only if members are not ready to vote
if more information is needed a tabling
motion is not
allowed and if we come to the point of
no
recommendation then without
recommendation that is the last motion
to that can be made if all others are
exhausted so the chair will ask are you
ready to vote the motion is whatever um
and all members present uh are asked to
vote and and I as the chair will call
your name and and uh you're on the
record with that um you will call yes
yeah starting with Vice chair yeah yes
and I start with the vice chair and then
the sheet goes through the the
Republicans and then through the
Democrats and the and the chair is the
last to be
called um and here's where again if the
now with the new uh policy if there's
you need to recuse you should have told
the uh uh chair ahead of time and myself
so that uh you won't be
called amendments are voted on
individually and if there's multiple
amendments and they don't conflict
they'll all be combined into one big
Amendment and reported out of the
committee as one Amendment
um uh you have to have any
amendments and and copies thereof ready
at the start of an executive
session they are identified by their
amendment number which is uh uh given by
the drafters um and amendments are may
be adopted by Voice vote show of hands
or roll call so that's new from last
year last year we we did everything by
roll call but it's uh the new guidance
is voice show of hands or roll call on
the
Amendments the final roll call is a
final roll call is required at the end
uh to get the final full committee
recommendation on on the
bill uh one can still change their vote
on any Bill if it is done while the the
uh the bill is still in control of the
committee once we're done and it's gone
you can't change that
vote
uh bills can be put on a consent
calendar if there's no objection uh and
they normally will be if there's uh two
or for more nay votes or excuse me more
than two nay votes the uh the custom is
we don't put it on the consent calendar
it's only on the regular
calendar no bills with a fiscal note or
or uh um any other appropriation uh can
be put on the on the consent calendar uh
with an ought to pass or ought to pass
with Amendment uh
vote reconsideration a motion for
reconsideration is appropriate and does
not require the member to
have uh make making a motion to have
voted on the prevailing side so anyone
can make a reconsideration motion and
it's again it's only possible if the
bill is still in the possession of the
committee committee
reports these are to be clear concise
summaries of the legislation and the
committee's reason for making the
recommendation the committee report only
becomes public when it's published in
the house
calendar
authors the member who made the motion
on the bill usually writes the committee
report any member voted with the
minority May write The Minority Report
only one member's name appears on the
majority and The Minority Report and
only per permanent members of a
committee May write a committee
report committee report should also
include a brief discussion of any
committee
Amendment finally it is the Chairman's
responsibility to review the majority
and the minority reports to ensure they
are accurate clear and
complete and grammatically correct and
written in a uniform style and the chair
should discuss any suggested uh
revisions with the author if any of the
any issues uh arise about its accuracy
clearness completeness grammatical
correctness or writing style the
ultimate review also on these rely with
the speaker of the house uh as the uh
clerk puts them on the
docket and the uh committee's final vote
count appears with the majority
report that's executive
sessions thank you Mr clerk all right
questions let's start with
representative McGee thank you Mr chair
um you you briefly alluded to um when
there's no recommendation so when
there's a tie vote coming out of
committee last year the rule was if you
had no recommendation and it went
through to to the house it went up as
OTP and there was discussion about
changing it or giving it to the chair's
discretion so what is the rule now if we
have a tie going to the house so last
Wednesday we changed that rule and now
the chairman of the committee can
designate when it goes to the house
floor without recommendation what the
first motion is so it used to be that it
was automatically OTP but now the chair
can say the first motion is itl
four representative Corman did you have
a question yeah I had a couple
um uh representative bernardy you you
mentioned that in the case of no
recommendation the final motion must be
no recommendation I don't recall that we
voted on a no recommendation motion
previously it's just that if neither
motion passed it was just no
recommendation okay and then the second
question is I remember we had um some
confusion last time about when there's
an an
otpa motion the exact order of of what
we do what motions so can can you please
go over that again what we'll do this
time yes we started off if we knew there
was an amendment we started off with the
amendment first and if that passed
then that was incorporated into the next
motion which was an ought to pass as
amended so the bill with the amendment
that we just passed so we take them in
that
order so there won't first be an otpa
motion the first motion would be for an
amendment before there's even an otpa
motion is that right that's my
understanding although I I am going to
uh clerk training again on
Wednesday uh and there may be a change
to how that's done and if there is I
will advise everyone before we meet and
I'm going to a chairs Vice chairs
meeting tomorrow morning I will ask that
question too to get clarification on
that I believe the process we're going
to use is we're going to make a motion
on the amendment first vote on that then
make a new motion ought to pass as
amended and vote on that I think that's
the way we're going to do it
representative Thomas Thomas a two-year
question representative Corman uh just
as a reminder when the motion comes up
for an amendment uh the amendment is
either approved or not approved there's
no OTP or anything like that so just so
amendments are approved or non-approved
and then you would go into the OTP or
otpa
uh type of thing just it's a it's a
technicality but that's that's how it's
normally
done and that's and that's why when I
was going over the notes uh we we said
uh the very first thing you you have to
have if you have an amendment it's got
to come to the chair so he knows about
it ahead of time it's not an amendment
that
emerges after we were well into the
discussion uh I mean there are times
that in the discussion of of a bill we
have said oh this really would be good
to have an amendment and we stopped the
executive session and sent things out
but that's that's not the normal way of
doing business normal way is your
amendments are all crafted numbered
ready to go ahead of time you start with
that first and then you uh you take
action on that either is adopted or not
if it's adopted then the next motion is
ought to pass with Amendment or as
amended representative Wendy Thomas
thank you Mr chair um there is well it's
there's no confusion on amendments but
each committee seems to do amendments
differently so for example I have a a
bill that's going into another committee
um it came out of os flawed so it
immediately needs an amendment so I
contacted the the the chair
and and told her the problem and she
said I can present the bill as well as
present the amendment but she wanted
somebody who was on the committee to be
a co-sponsor of the
amendment last term I think you would
not let
any Prime sponsors bring forward an
amendment is that still standing
especially knowing that OSS has made
many many many
mistakes yeah I've heard a lot about
mistakes coming out of os this year
unfortunately so the way I have done it
in the past and the way I would
recommend that people do this is to
submit written testimony when you
testify on your bill and include the
language of your amendment in your
written testimony with a
heading of the nature of I hope the
committee will consider an
amendment that reflects the following
language and then you create
exactly the language that you want
to be in the
amendment because amendments are really
the province of the
committee so when a bill goes to a
committee is assigned to a committee
that bill becomes the committee's bill
it's no longer the sponsor's bill and so
amendments according to the rules are
supposed to come from a Committee Member
but if you provide the committee with
the language that that you would like to
see in your Amendment then one of the
members can easily pick that up and see
that that gets submitted on your behalf
so that's the way I would do it that's
the way I encourage us to do it in this
committee representative
parshall thank you chair does it go
without saying that the committee can
also decide to amend the language as
offered yes
absolutely one other thing I would say
about um committee
reports and there was a lengthy
discussion of this in the chairs and
vice chairs training session that we had
a couple of weeks ago and Paul Smith the
clerk spent a lot of time talking about
this he and the speaker review every
single committee report majority report
and Minority Report and he
said that it's incumbent upon committee
chairs to make sure that all committee
reports are reflective of the facts that
emerged during the committee public
hearing a committee report whether it's
majority or minority is not intended to
be a statement of opinion on the behalf
of the report writer it needs to be a
summary of important facts that emerged
from from the public hearing
and he urged committee chairs if they
don't get that in a Minority Report to
return it to the writer to the author
with instructions for a rewrite
so be careful of that be sensitive to
that when you write a Minority Report or
a majority report leave your own
opinions out just report the facts of
what you heard in the public hearing
doesn't matter what uh side those facts
support just report the facts that you
heard okay representative Vice chair
Thomas yeah just just to add to what
chairman V said the clerk also
reiterated that there is a timeline to
get those reports in and the the chair
will put that
timeline if someone says there will be a
Minority Report and a Minority Report is
not
forthcoming and misses the timeline then
the calendar will reflect no Minority
Report um and that's what the clerk said
uh so uh please get your reports in on
time uh and work with the chair if you
have to do any
revision to make it on easy on yourself
if you anticipate that you will be
writing either a majority or a Minority
Report you could always write it the
night before the executive session and
bring it with you then you could hand it
in before you leave executive session
that day that would make your life a lot
easier rather than going home and trying
to remind yourself oh I've got to write
this report chairman Vos needs it at 2
o'cl on Wednesday but I have to go see
the doctor on Wednesday morning and save
yourself that hassle write the report
the night before and bring it with
you now everybody received a
handout uh next year name plate when you
came in this
morning about a way to request copies of
electon electronic documents through
house committee Services hang on to this
because you might need it before the
session is over there's also a small
document here that uh gives you a
pointer to house committee services
Davis Allen is our new committee
researcher Davis please say stand up and
say
hi taking over from Chris the officer
who has moved on to uh bigger and better
things one would assume but uh Davis
will be here throughout the year to uh
support the committee if you
have research requests or
other house committee service requests
to make you can talk to Davis and I
trust all of you have met Robin who is
in the office behind that door she's our
new administrator Carrie um retired
after last year so she's now a lady of
leisure there's Robin hi
Robin so please uh feel free to chat
with Robin if you need anything in the
way of uh Services she can help you with
copies she can help you with um
dates and also make sure you keep your
eye open for email from Robin because
Robin is the one who sends out the
notices of committee activity in the
email so when I uh ask her to schedule a
public hearing or an executive session
she sends out the notice to everyone and
so if you're not watching the calendar
you could watch your email and that way
you'll always know when our hearings and
sessions are scheduled
representative Vice chair Thomas uh
thank you Mr chair uh to the new members
since the subject of emails came up if
you have a personal email that you would
rather um have it out there to maybe you
can get to it easier rather than the one
that was given to you which is you know
legi state New Hampshire whatever um for
my benefit I sometimes send out emails
to the entire committee like if we're
planning a um uh a field trip somewhere
or or or or something like that uh
please uh email me the email that you
would like to have me put into my list
so I know that it'll get to you perhaps
faster than the one you have
listed representative McGee yeah I just
wanted to mention I hope everybody has
noticed or seen the notice that the
emails are also changing so instead of
it being Dole after your name it'll be
uh gc. nh.gov
so we have to actually sign in sign out
on the 21st so that's coming up soon so
I just thought I'd mention it the 21st
of this month yes okay thank
you all right anybody have anything else
representative partiall sorry again
thank you uh chair
um I noticed that youing up email
um I notice there's a time change on
tomorrow's meeting it was originally
scheduled for 9:00 I believe now it's
scheduled for
9:00 no no no no the the start time 9
the the start time has always been 9:00
the the notice that went out about a
time change was about a time change for
the public hearing tomorrow afternoon
okay it was originally scheduled for
4:00 but I got a call from the speakers
office and he said that's too late
because I haven't been able to arrange
for overtime for this committee staff so
if we'd have gone past five o'l people
would have Robin and Davis and other
house committee Services people would be
working
overtime and it wouldn't be authorized
so he asked me to move the meeting up to
3:30 so we're starting that public
hearing on House Bill 106 sure you saw
that Tony at uh at 3:30 tomorrow
afternoon and we have to be out of here
before
5:00 so the the public hearing will end
no later than
4:45 Tony I just have a a concern about
that because I know there's going to be
people showing up to testify so what
happens if not everybody gets a chance
to speak are you gonna maybe postpone it
well if people follow our eate etiquette
and submit their pink cards let's say I
get 10 of them then I'll just decide um
okay nobody can speak longer than 4
minutes or something like
that okay anything else well I think
this has been an excellent opening day
I'm really happy to meet our new members
and grateful for the participation of
our returning members looking forward to
a good two-year session we've got a lot
of work to do but this is a great group
of people to do it and so I'm looking
forward to it and I thank you all we'll
see you tomorrow 9:00 Sharp